we've been seeing a lot of really creepy
stuff with schools
what they're teaching kids this critical
race applied principles
there was a story we covered the other
day where you get these little kids and
they're showing these questionnaires
they're asked
and this is what everyone whatever you
want to call it it's it's it's getting
to the kids
it's affecting their their ability to
strive to succeed it's telling them that
they can't succeed on the basis of their
race and things like this
this wave of what the left has referred
to with the establishment has called
social justice in my opinion is mostly
about gaining power
political power corporate power
otherwise and there's one
story that happened several years ago
and it's about the ceo of a very large
and prominent company
being essentially falsely accused or i
should say
the the media spun a narrative that this
ceo
was a racist for describing a slur
in fact saying it was a bad thing to say
but it doesn't matter and it wasn't just
uh papa john schnatter who's i pronounce
it right right schnatter
schneider who's here with us today there
was also another story that i brought up
in this old video
about netflix where a guy was actually
doing a training where he was like here
are the words to avoid and by simply
saying the word in a descriptive way
to tell people it was bad ended up
losing his job now that one was crazy
because the guy ends up going to hr
where they're like what happened he said
i was explaining to people that
you know these words were bad enough to
say them and they're like what words and
he says it again
and then they're shocked oh he said it
to us again he was you asked him what he
said and he was saying it was wrong
cancel culture is real and it's been
it's been going on for some time
and it's evolving this is why i brought
up what's happening with kids with
critical race applied principle because
this is
the extension the evolution or another
component of what we saw with cancel
culture
now we see a lot of people in media
saying cancer culture is not real it
doesn't exist because all these rich and
famous people they're still rich and
famous
but here's a story of a guy who did
nothing wrong who was ousted from his
own company started taking his name down
from buildings
now that's insane and in my opinion it's
an effort for
for some group to gain power in this
instance it sounds like corporate
political interests realized
they could manipulate public perception
and opinion because
everyone thinks obviously racism is bad
so they can twist things
use a morsel of truth and and build it
up into a conspiracy
theory or some false accusation that you
you can't really falsify
we're going to talk about that and we're
going to talk a bit about just what's
going on the labor market what's going
on with our kids
and we are joined by the ceo i'm sorry
i'm sorry the former
ceo of uh uh papa john's john schneider
do you want to just quickly introduce
yourself
john schneider thanks ian thanks tim for
having me proud to be here and i think
you told me to lead it off with better
ingredients
better pizza papa john's i used to
i got to be honest um i did this video
you you you were talking about how i did
this video in 2018 and you're like it
was spot on and everything
i vowed never to buy papa john's again
because of what they did to you because
it was
i i read the news and i'm like this is
clearly bs
here's a guy who's on a phone call
saying like hey here's a bad word people
shouldn't say
and they're like we're gonna fire him
and destroy his life now because of it
and
i used to think that the better
ingredients better pizza thing was just
marketing i was like yeah yeah
i'd see i'd see on the tv and i'd be
like yeah yeah yeah better ingredients
what does that mean
well uh no i actually we actually we
order pizza all the time and when we do
we order papa john's because we lo
i looked up the ingredients i'm not
going to name the other pizza places
uh call them out specifically because
you know lawsuits or whatever but these
other big chains they put weird stuff in
their pizza
they put one company put splenda in
their crust
and that to me was just just weird so
the potassium bromate is ready
what is concerning it's like a leavening
agent can you explain it a little better
anything that's processed food is the
fda approves which unfortunately
usually is chemical based i mean you can
get a can of
soup from campbell's and it's got 20 or
30 chemicals in it so the thing we tried
to do
throughout the history of papa john's
was get rid of the chemicals
nitrates there were cellulose in the
cheese
anything of some of the preservatives
anything to keep it more natural
more original we thought we thought the
more natural
the more authentic uh the better would
be for um
you know for the kids um and we just
weren't convinced those chemicals in the
food processing
process were not uh we're not unhealthy
so we eliminated as many as those
as we could and hopefully to this day
they're still doing that
hopefully to this day but we'll get into
all that stuff so you know ian's i'm so
glad you're here john
papa john's the the recipe it was the
ingredients but it changed my life in
the 90s
it was like revolutionary for pizza
do you guys remember 1994 95 i mean what
year did you guys really hit
we went public june of 93 with 232
stores
and literally i couldn't take the family
on vacation
for five or ten grand didn't have the
money and the next day we went public
and the company was worth 150 million
bucks in one day so it was like i was 31
years old it's like we just went
we just made 100 million bucks like wow
it was pretty wild
we i i want to talk about that too
obviously we'll talk about the more
political stuff but just hearing the
story of the success how to build a
company i'm sure a lot of people want to
know
you know tips for success right we can
talk about that you know good strategy
can overcome
mediocre tactics but bad strategy can't
overcome great tactics so
from the get-go we were always authentic
and about quality
but we didn't really have a tagline so
we read the book um
positioning by jack trout and already
1969
of all and read the book and talked
about how you differentiate your product
with your slogan it's got to be truthful
you know volvo safety
fedex is overnight et cetera so we hired
jack trout to come in he was 10
000 bucks a day wow and uh he comes in
this is like
95 96. and he's over there he looks at
our fresh pack sauce from
the quarter posse family out at
stanislaus he looks at the way we're
making our fresh dough
the attention to water put a little more
on real cheese he's going
well heck you use better ingredients i
said well of course he goes
well better ingredients make a better
pizza and i'll go
yeah he goes well that's your slogan i
spent ten thousand dollars
took him about 20 seconds there you go
so that was pretty
cool let's let's get to that stuff get
into that stuff too we got lydia press
on the button i am pressing buttons in
the corner i'm very excited to meet papa
john because i learned to drive on a
camaro and his story about
recovering his lost camaro is like a
hero story to me so i'm
i'm loving it i'm enjoying talking to
him are you 76 or 77
it was a 77 76 beautiful so much fun
all right everybody before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member
to get an ad free experience and
exclusive access to the timcast members
only podcast
you're also helping to support our
journalists of which we are hiring more
people we had two more people start just
the other day
we're gonna be producing a lot more
shows so as a member not only to get
access to this stuff but we'll be adding
more and more content to it as we build
culture
instead of just complaining about the
culture war so again go to timcast.com
but don't forget to like this video
share this show with your friends
subscribe hit the notification bell
assuming all that matters and let's just
uh we're just going to jump in and have
this conversation
i want to hear the uh the story tell us
what happened so um real quick real
quick just the
general context is i think it was 2018
the story breaks
that you the you know at the time the
ceo papa john's on a phone call
and they said in this i think it was a
forbes article right it was forbes
article came out
claiming that you used a racial slur or
something
and then all of a sudden this was like a
cascade of them kicking you out of your
company
they were trying to claim that you were
a racist and all these really awful
things
and then the media just began to twist
everything out of proportion and lie
about what was happening
now i guess the crazy thing is it sounds
like the way you described it like a
conspiracy
against you well you got to kind of go
back a little bit in time as
it was a a training call and we were
talking about race which is very
sensitive
and we were the do's and don'ts and
unbeknownst to me
they they taped the conversation and
throughout the call they
they tried to debate me when i was
looking at people so who who is oh the
laundry service the ad agency was trying
to get me round up and to say something
and that was going to hurt myself but i
didn't know that at the time that that
was a it was a setup so
they kept that one little clip and
fortunately for me i feel like i'm the
luckiest guy in the world because they
accidentally left the tape running so as
soon as they hung up with me
they kept talking about hey we got him
we're gonna send him out really oh yeah
we got the tape
we got him on tape i got a tape so we
have the truth this was a complete setup
they set on for about five weeks and
they said if you don't give us six
million dollars
washerman and laundry service we're
going to bury the founder
and i went to the ceo and to the board
and i said hey they're trying to extort
six million dollars
if we don't give them six million
dollars they said they're going to bury
the founder that's extortion we should
call the fbi
and so that it blew up
and the company just let it happen
that's what makes me think the company
was uh co-co-inspired in this because
the company didn't do an investigation
they didn't set up a special committee
to investigate
and if they would have they would have
seen there was a tape
the truth was i didn't say something
that was racist what i said was
anti-racist they changed the narrative
well we had to issue a quick
clarification because of the likes of
people like ibrahim x kennedy
anti-racist actually means racist and
i'm not i'm not i'm not kidding i mean
it sounds funny right
but uh candy is the i guess he's the the
progenitor of anti-racism
which is an ideology that states
in his uh i got to be very careful how i
say this for obvious reasons i mean like
we're talking about
kennedy says that he wants racial
discrimination so anti-racism according
to him
is more racial discrimination so that's
why
you know they they they take these
phrases and try to control them and
that's part of how they
they play this game so to put it simply
you're you're the ceo of this company
you're doing a regular training phone
call it was like a sensitivity trainer
or something right exactly
telling people not to be racist to be to
be excellent to each other
and the the statement you made was that
you said something about i think it was
colonel sanders
was it sanders colonel sanders was
habitual about using the m word in a
derogatory manner and
in my mind that was a no-go that's abs
absolutely something a founder doesn't
do so we were using him
uh metaphorically as an example of what
not to do
and because you're like hey this is a
bad thing don't be like him they were
like we got him
yes they recorded you and i didn't i
didn't know that about the uh the
recording where they admitted
or they they're like yeah we got them
haha yeah when i heard they recorded the
conversation i went
good because what i said was anti-racist
i knew what i said they asked me to
apologize
the next week and i said i apologize for
the misunderstanding i apologize for
what happened
but if i apologize for saying something
that's anti-racist
then that's racist and i wasn't going to
apologize yeah i got to point out
i said this before the show talking
about a racial slur and the history of
the word
and its mechanics and how people feel
about it is different than calling
someone that word
completely different in fact you can
call someone a very nice word in a
horribly mean way
and be more offensive than talking about
a slur oh yeah like if you were talking
to a woman and you're like oh you're so
beautiful aren't you
yeah you look great today right the way
you say it but here's
i got to add to that ian it wasn't it's
not just describing the word
john was actually saying it was a bad
thing yeah it was it was actually
saying don't be racist yeah but i think
in life you've got to own your own you
got to take the hit
and you know we're not going to bs your
your audience there's three things we
can all agree on one is they set me up
no doubt about it it was a setup two is
they reverse what i said
i didn't i didn't use the word draw i i
quoted cited
paraphrase what somebody else says that
i would never say and three
i shouldn't have said the word you
should not have said the word
yeah that's how they got you yeah it's
it's it's really challenging
that we're in a space now where well let
me just go back in time george carlin
everybody loved george carlin he was a
hero on the left and he has a bit where
he goes on stage
and says as many racial slurs as he can
and then
actually calls two very prominent black
comedians the n word and even i like by
today's standards i'm like wow
like that's brutal man i i'm i'm not
sure i feel about that
but george carl was making a point that
just saying the word
isn't what's what's so bad about it
what's bad is it's the person behind the
word of the things they're doing with it
now i gotta i gotta admit i'm not a a
complete fan
of the end of that bit from carlin even
like especially by today's standards i'm
kind of like well i don't think
that that was appropriate saying the
racial stories i understand the issue is
you got to be able to say words to tell
people what the words are you know what
i mean like
it would i i think the problem with you
saying the word was that
they were able to manipulate that in the
press
changing it from john says a word and
describes it as something you don't say
and can criticize someone for saying it
to john used a racial slur
used it as if to imply you called
someone a name
the challenge now is there there are
instances where i was actually was
talking to somebody
we have we have people come on come on
the show all the time asking us about
censorship and what do we have to watch
out for because we know youtube is
very very bad happy and then someone was
like
are we allowed to say the n-word and i
was like what i was like absolutely not
are you joking like you don't i'm not
i'm not a fan of that
and they're like really i was like even
like in the context of world war ii and
i went
you mean nazi and they're like yeah yeah
because you can't say that either
like just by saying that youtube's
algorithm would probably flag this video
down rank it demonetize or whatever
simply for bringing up
a word like that and so there there were
these instances where i was talking to
people
explaining to them the problem with not
being able to even describe
things anymore there is a very famous
documentary
about a man named james baldwin i cannot
tell you the name of that documentary
because youtube
could ban us for simply saying the name
of the documentary
and it's not using the the n word as
most people know it it's a different n
word we also can't say
and how am i supposed to describe to
people the various
words that can't be said if there's a
bunch of different words that start with
the letter n
this is the problem and so when i heard
that story about you i was like well how
do you tell your employees
don't say these words when you can't
actually tell them what the word is
well i think there's no place for the
word period
um the thing i like about what you're
doing on the weekend is you work on
your culture you know you're trying to
change things and and set an example
and make the world a better place and so
anything
that further divides our country
anything that doesn't really involve
like kindness
and thoughtfulness and consideration and
collaborative alliances for our fellow
man i think
that should just be off the table
because um
the media kind of thrives on fear um to
your point if the
journalist the media would have done
what you did you all you did is do a
little homework
you know you looked at the stories and
thought about it
thought about it and you got it right i
mean i i can't believe it you're 32
years old
um you weren't where you're at today
back then
and you nailed it you nailed it to a t
what happened and if
journalists really cared about their
dignity and their integrity
i think i think the approval rating
right now networks i think that 15
percent or something
oh it's miserable is it miserable and i
think it's because they're not honest
and i think the american people are
tired of being lied to but
what i want to do with this situation is
i want to find a way
to emphasize forgiveness pardon the
unpardonable forgive the unforgivable
and let everybody know that sometimes
you're going to get a raw deal
and sometimes you're going to get kicked
in the teeth and that's
not cool especially in this situation
because the race thing is about
it's pretty pretty brutal to be painted
in that box especially on a false
narrative
but if we can find a way to for other
folks to inspire them to get through
their adversity then
that would be to me that would be the
bang for a buck that i get out
of going through all this it is
extremely challenging though
i mean when you when you have what we're
seeing in schools
there it's the it's critical race
applied principles they call it critical
race praxis
crp we call it applied principles
because the acronym is a little bit
more accurate in my opinion but you have
them
you know just going to children and
they're teaching children to be racist
so yeah i mean we if it's not i agree
with what you're saying you know we want
to we want to
inspire people to be kind to be critical
thinkers to improve themselves
to build a culture people need to be
responsible to a certain degree we want
to help each other but we also have some
responsibility
well what's happening now is you try to
be nice
you try to be forgiving they take
advantage of it
they come after you i mean take a look
at exactly what happened to you i mean
i understand what you're saying you know
forgive the unforgivable and or pardon
the unpardonable
but the people that you know uh
i guess conspired against you they've
learned no lesson
in fact they've enriched themselves so
uh
it sounds like you mentioned this a
second ago that this ad agency
i think it was right they were recording
you they set you up
but that even within your own company
there were people who seem to be seem to
be working against you
yeah we had a couple board members um
steve ritchie was the ceo who was
getting ready to get terminated so
you know he had to be part of this to
set me up because he was going to get uh
so so you weren't the ceo no it wasn't
the cos chairman of the board oh okay
okay i was wrong correction
another gentleman mark shapiro who was
head of governance um
he wanted the marketing business and uh
after he knew that as long as i was
chairman of the board and involved
that it was a conflict of interest for a
board of director to have
an account the marketing count of course
when i got off the board
the first thing they did was gave mark
shapiro the 40 million dollar
marketing deal and he got a 10 million
dollar package wow so
um a complete violation of duty of
loyalty but
we had a couple of board members that
they had personal gain
a company was making a lot a lot of
money
and we had a
washerman who owned laundry service they
had agency he was good friends with
roger goodell
remember i'm hammering goodell in the
paper going tell get your act roger
goodell is the commissioner of the nfl
um i'm hammering him that you know you
got to get this solved to the players
and owner satisfaction so goodell didn't
like being called out on that so we had
we got goodell we got washerman with
laundry service
uh steve richie with papa john's and
mark shapiro
they set me up the rest of the board
didn't do their due diligence they
didn't do an investigation they went
along with it and we end up
with a complete disaster that really
hurt my employees
it hurt my franchisees very badly and it
hurt my community of louisville kentucky
they left my hometown when i lost
control they left my
hometown so i'll be fine you know
we'll live to see another day i've got a
lot of things i'm working on i'm excited
about
but a lot of good hard-working people
that wake up
and woke up every day to make papa
john's great they lost their jobs and
their families got hurt
and that that's not cool you know why i
think the other board members didn't
stand up for you they didn't want to
appear in the news to be defending
someone was accused of racism
so it wasn't about doing an
investigation it was about i'm not
sticking my neck out and get involved in
this
we see what these people do when they
when they go around smashing windows and
starting fires
the last thing anyone's wants to do is
be on their radar yeah i think there was
an element of cowardness
to this i think the board members took
the easy way out said okay
we'll just pin all this on john we'll
pin up our own job we'll take the lazy
way out and uh the easy way out and um
you know and to make john the hit guy
the make john the fall man and that's
what they did yeah i agree with that yep
but that's okay but you know because you
don't you don't gain anywhere in life
but being the victim
so you know right they did it you know i
got a two-inch violin can we play
let's play it for three seconds and get
on with life because you know it's you
you got to figure out a way to use this
whole i don't know if you want to call
it an episode or uh
what a chapter in the book whatever we
got to find a way to propel this and use
this to our advantage to make society
better were you freaking out when all
started happening [ __ ] i didn't i didn't
know what happened
i treat everybody with kindness and
respect i mean i and
um we we were raised so so good
with regards to respecting everybody
regardless of the skin color that
that was just part of our family and um
so i knew it was bs i knew it wasn't
truthful so but i didn't understand how
it happened
how do you take something best place to
work in kentucky making 160 million
bucks a year
we're growing we just passed 5 000
stores and how do you make it into this
mess on a false narrative
and so i didn't really quite understand
it and then
probably two or three months after this
broke it was like
you know i think they set me up i mean
really and then
here it is three years later we still
can't get documents from papa john's
we're still waiting on 13 000 documents
three years later that's how bad see we
have the setup
and now we have the cover up next
question is who done it
how far up the food chain does this go
you're you're are you still suing
finally yeah we have a litigation right
now with laundry service casey
washington laundry service
and we're waiting on 13 000 documents
they've got
six lawyers between the two of them and
they fought this for eight months
and papa john's has fallen to 220 now
for two and a half years
so either they have something that's
really bad or they're stringing us out
but if they have something that that's
not bad they're sure doing a heck of a
job hiding it from us
you said it was three months right and
you started to question whether you
think that you got set up well the first
thing you do in bed you lay in bed every
night and you cry
you go wow what the hell just
how am i going to get out of this i mean
i just got painted as a racist
i mean you just sit there and you don't
know you don't know what to do
because you're you're kind of brain dead
you're numb your brain is numb because
you don't understand
um how they could take something that
was that benign
and anti-racist it was a sensitivity
training
of what not to say and then flip it leak
remember forbes said
he said the m work but then what they
didn't say is he said he never uses the
n-word
colonel sanders used it so they took it
out of a context
but it was probably five or six months
into it i went
okay this was a set up and then we
started putting the pizzas
pieces together pizzas
hopefully we won't get barred on youtube
for that one putting the pizzas together
um and then probably a year and a half
and it was like okay
and now every piece i've never seen
lawsuits they do this they go up and
they go down they go up and they go down
this lawsuit has been going on for 15
months every single
every single thing that's happened has
been to our benefit
so i think we've got a pretty ironclad
case on what happened
if we just get the other side to operate
with a little transparency we'll get to
the bottom
of it frankly at the end of the day all
papa john's has got to do is say
he was set up he's no history of
treating anybody
with less than the utmost respect and
dignity
we're sorry john had to go through with
this he's the face of the brand
it's his name on the box it's his recipe
it's his concept
let's all move on with our lives in a
positive way
unfortunately the board of directors
papa john's does not we talk about
coward
does not have enough solid sense of self
to take the hit
and admit they didn't do a proper
investigation they made a huge mistake
uh they panicked and they did a lot of
damage to this brand
panic i wonder i i i wonder i mean it
sounds like a setup it sounds like
people wanted to make some money
and they did and then it sounds like the
other people were just like hey i'm not
sticking my neck out for this
like i said you know we see what happens
you know uh
with these these extremists who go
around with with molotov cocktails and
crowbars and bats smashing windows and
attacking people
that's scary people are scared of what's
going to happen yeah well let's get
let's get back on the positive
way yeah yeah you take coca-cola delta
they need to be flying airplanes and
making soft drinks you know papa john's
needs to be making pizzas but when you
have a weak board
and they get this pressure from all
these you know these
this political aspect and this group
that's probably the silent you know the
or the loud squeaky wheel
squeaky then they they do silly things
and they need to fly airplanes
and get people there safe and sound and
they need to make sodi pop and papa
john's needs to make pizza
but some for some reason these these
boards are so
they pretend like they're leaders in our
community and they're put together and
they have high integrity and dignity and
they're really made like paper dolls
you know any negative pr they just fold
like puppets
and i had a weak board and it cost me
dearly yeah
i think uh i think there's
gen x maybe i guess gen xers and uh
younger boomers are much more interested
in no confrontation
and so now you have very loud prominent
activists they've they've found their
voice online they've found followers
fighting for what they will call justice
and then you get board members who are
like
look i make a bunch of money i don't
want to be in the press i'm not going to
be involved so i won't be
right yeah three percent of the
population causes 85 percent of the
problems
you know three percent so it's at um
that very
boisterous small percent that
tear things up tear buildings up tear
cities up
you know and um you know do crazy things
um that cause the rest of us a lot of
grief politicians they
i think you know the worst thing out of
everything when i saw this story about
you was that
it this was one of one of the most um
if you wanna if you wanna if you wanna
call out cancel culture
we'll talk you know i think the you put
cancel culture and encyclopedia they
show a picture of what happened
of you and what happened to you they
didn't just get you fired you know
removed from your position
they started going after your legacy
there was i think you you had
contributed to a university is that what
happened they took your name down
yes four four universities which ones
uofl
uk ball state and purdue so you had
contributed to these universities they
took your names
they took the your name off of these
these places well we believe in
voluntary exchange
we believe that when you um go out and
you
buy product or service it's mutually
beneficial to all parties
that's what free markets do so the
curriculum that we set up in each
university was free markets
voluntary exchange entrepreneurship and
we were up to four universities
um the left and i won't make this
political but the left did not like us
in the universities uh the group i went
in with
um and this was uh tens of millions of
dollars to do this
we had two goals uh the first goal is to
give the kids both sides of the coin
they hear about entitlement
how good you know big brother big
government is you know if you're
successful
that's not good you don't have to be
accountable a
big bureaucracy we flipped it and said
okay that's fine you want to believe
that you believe whatever but
you might look at entrepreneurship
accountability self-respect
making a contribution uh earning uh
saving getting ahead
and then and so they the kids loved uh
the entrepreneur program they really did
and um whether they went this way or
that way i don't care as long as they
could see both sides of the coin
that was goal number one goal number two
was don't further divide
uh the country the country's already
divided um this was
five six years ago let's don't further
divide the country and i really feel
like we were accomplishing that goal
and of course our terminology our
nomenclature
the left couldn't get on it because we
were not there to divide we were there
just to
teach free markets and so i think the
left really had um
an issue with us going into these
universities and teaching free markets
free enterprise and entrepreneurship
wow yeah you were having a i didn't even
know that yeah i just saw the story
where it's like name was removed from
school and i'm like that's crazy
but now it sounds like you were actually
having a very very powerful impact on
young people and teaching them
personal responsibility yeah the first
the second year at uofl
uh out of 263 curriculums
our program got was number four within
two years so the kids love
entrepreneurship
they they love hearing about free
markets and freedoms in general
and so when we were at four we wanted to
go to 400
because we think small business
is the backbone in the heartbeat of this
country i mean 60 something percent of
the new jobs are small business
so we like mike rowe with dirty jobs
we like teaching vocations we like
teaching trades
we like teaching entrepreneurship i even
wanted a classroom on the front of the
building school and then trades in the
back how do you build a house you know
how do you work on a truck
you know how you do the technical part
of a carburetor on a toyota or whatever
it is
but we actually wanted the school room
adjacent to
the workshop a micro kind of deal to
teach these kids how to have a career
how have a job so they don't get out of
college you know
you know 150 000 in debt on student
loans do you think that there was maybe
a political component to
what happened to you then i mean you've
got you've got special interests that
don't want what you're teaching kids in
these universities they certainly
ripped that out the moment they could
well you're asking the conspiracy
question
um well i guess is the conspiracy beyond
just being set up by
you know people who want to make money
was there a political component i
you know i don't want to say anything i
really don't have facts i know richie
and shapiro
were part of it i know washington's down
with laundry service as part of goodell
was probably part of it
how far up the food chain that goes uh
washington's the head of the dnc and
la i don't really want to make that
assumption
i will say this i made a comment that
says roger goodell
needs to solve the nfl issues to the
players and owner satisfaction
less than 20 minutes that went viral
that i was against the players kneeling
i mean i'm like how did they take that
that was
a lie a lie benign inoculus and turn it
into
that i'm anti-annealing and within one
art we had like
six million it just blew up so
i'm kind of like was that orchestrated
well do you have you ever heard of the
phrase a standalone complex
emergent yeah so a lot of people
you know conspiracy is a dirty word and
yeah i gotta be honest i'm fairly
anti-conspiracy in a lot
of ways because you need a lot of
evidence to back up these big stretches
however when you tell a story like that
that you said
you know solve this to the players and
the coaches benefits that you said
players and coaches or
players goodell needs to solve this
debacle
to the owners and players satisfaction
right right to take that
and clearly take it out of context to
make you look bad
a standalone complex would be when a
bunch of people
do something that effectively acts in
concert
to create the appearance of a conspiracy
but they're actually just doing it
independently
so if you had 10 people who all stood up
at the same time
and yelled that they were you know fans
of papa john's people would assume they
orchestrated it
that would be a conspiracy they they
sort of they came together and planned
it at ten o'clock we're all going to
stand up and shout we like pizza
a standalone complex would be seemingly
by chance they all stood up at the same
time independent of each other for some
reason
so when you see what happened to you
perhaps it doesn't need to be a
conspiracy
it could just be that when people saw
there was an opportunity to go after you
political components were like now's our
chance to get rid of these free
enterprise programs in these
universities
and so they did i think that concept is
definitely could be
applicable to my situation for this to
happen
all the stars had to align perfectly in
the wrong way for me
and that could have happened that could
have happened regarding like building
entrepreneurial skills for young people
what was your
young entrepreneurial career like like
when did you get your first job and what
led you up to start making the pizzas
the greatest lesson i
ever had was um when i was eight my
grandfather had kind of like a farm
miniature farm where we had tractors and
mowers and equipment
and um he'd go out and buy new equipment
and tractors but every once in a while i
would break
and like the motor would break on the
tractor and he would look at me and say
fix it
and i said fix it well i'm eight years
old
seven years old eight years old you know
so i'd tear the motor apart
the carburetor part on his workbench and
sometimes i could get it back together
and sometimes i couldn't
he didn't care he wanted me to know how
things worked he wanted to know how to
help for me to know how to turn a wrench
to to understand that the engineering
the mechanics of how things really work
that was by far
you know how how do ecosystems work how
does the environment work how does the
weather work you know how do political
systems work how does our economy work
how does our banking system work
that all came back when i was 78 years
old when he
wasn't both he and my dad said it's okay
to make a mistake
you know you're not going to learn if
you're not making mistakes now don't
make the same mistake twice
but an entrepreneur is um nothing
but a big shot's nothing but a little
shot that kept on shooting so just keep
on shooting
keep on trying new things and new
innovations keep tinkering here
go ahead yo you're being taught to think
critically
to think independently to be personally
responsible
you tell that story and i'm like well
that makes perfect sense you plant that
seed
and here you are this very successful
businessman
and then you look at the school programs
you said that there were two different
programs right you wanted people to be
able to see both sides yours was free
enterprise what was the other thing they
were teaching what was the other
component
big government um tax the rich success
is a bad thing
entitlements um you know the the number
one
employer for history majors in the
united states is starbucks
you know that's that's true yeah i mean
they would teach they want to teach soft
science
you know i wanted to always teach hard
science arithmetic
you know engineering a veterinarian for
example that would be a
great career um how to build something
um architecture
you know those are things that are hard
scientists that you can actually
do something with and have a real career
at uofl we were
we had 200 slots in our dentistry
program
and we had demand for 3 000 dentists i'm
like we need more dentists i mean
you know we don't need more lawyers we
don't need more social science folks we
need more engineers we
need more architects we need more
dentists i'm curious as to how this is
happening how
you could have the the the program that
espouses
independence individuality
entrepreneurship that's the one that
gets removed i mean that should be the
resilient
side of things right you do have a way
with turning things on their head let me
chew on what you just said because you
just did
in real time which you did back in 2018.
you're right they threw me out
on something i didn't say and the very
thing that we're trying to produce
was exactly what i didn't say so that's
kind of interesting
well what i mean is if you teach people
to be responsible independent smart
cunning
and to be good people to try and help
others
how is it that these are the ideals that
seem to be faltering
you know particularly in this story but
in in my experience i think a lot of
people are seeing it
you tend to have the big government you
know entitlements
side becoming more and more prominent
gaining control of the institutions
maybe there's something that the uh
being a good person misses i'm not
saying don't be a good person
but maybe when you're a good person you
overlook the fact that some people might
be lying to you
well um again back to with your your
audience here on you know you gotta you
gotta own your own
uh bs you gotta own your own nonsense
and so
the question for the house is i mean i
protected my board of directors with my
life
i protected my employees with my life i
protected my franchisees i mean i
lo i made sure that nothing was going to
happen to them
and okay we we now have established they
want the 160 million they want the
marketing business they want
you know so they want to get rid of john
live with that okay
um can we have a cup of coffee and say
john you go we'll go
no conversation no nothing not only do
you want to get rid of me
they wanted the crucifixion they wanted
to you know they wanted to paint me in a
racist now
that's evil i mean that is about as bad
as you can do to a founder of a pizza
company that did it by the book that
played the long game
and took everybody up with it and the
question before the house is
how come i didn't see that i had no
inclination
that this board of directors and this
executive team would do something like
this
not even a witch that they were even
capable of doing this
and they did it they continue to do it
and so what i've tried to get out of
this
is okay how can i use that for higher
level of consciousness
awareness why didn't i see it but then
you got to flip that on its head and go
i don't want to go around life going i
got to worry about
people screwing me every second today so
um you can see we haven't quite reached
the
forgive the unforgivable uh we're
definitely off
um i'm gonna kill these people we're off
that one which is where we're at back
here
literally um but it's uh it's a lot to
take in
it's it's a lot to overcome but we we to
move on with the life we have to get to
that
that forgiveness stage we have to yeah
it kind of feels like um people who are
trying to be nice and do good are
unsuspecting of
you know what's going to come after them
and the story
you tell me about uh you know i know
people who work for papa john's i said
it was fantastic
i remember i was reading some quotes
where you were saying that you know
people got to get paid more the minimum
wage was too low
i've heard you you know you basically
talked about things that are fairly
populist right
help for the for the little guy and for
the working class and sure enough
maybe you know i don't describe it but
you you
may be too nice you know well you
understand papa john's and
and we we did build a great uh company
but we also had great people we had a
great team we really
were more in the people business in the
pizza business it was a fantastic group
of
individuals and that's how we got the
thing over 5 000 stores
um but i think you can't
you know you you just got to stay
positive with us and
um i think that if you take care of
people
and you do the right thing then sooner
or later you know karma's karma's the
real deal i mean karma you know what
goes around comes around
you're definitely right about
forgiveness i think we're about to enter
the age of like more transparency
especially in government and when we
start changing our government there's
going to be we're going to start finding
all these crimes and criminals within
the politicians
and it's going to be really you know
people are really going to want to
punish them but i think we have to
forgive
these people hillary clinton's email
scandals for instance we got to forgive
these people and make sure that if we
move forward to society it's all
together
otherwise those rich people in the
shadows are going to try and avoid
getting caught and they're going to try
and do damage to the people
attempting to move the system forward so
i'm full with you about this forgiveness
era
i mean some people are really really
dead yeah but really
it's not up for up to us to decide in my
opinion i i don't think we can do it if
we don't do it together
all of us as weird as it sounds horrible
if there's no justice for horrible
crimes then people lose faith in the
system because i've already lost faith
man because the justices and you don't
you don't bring it back by saying
bad people get can get away with bad
things well good people you know the ben
franklin quote
100 guilty people better to escape than
one
innocent suffer i think that maybe
that's ten thousand guilties
should escape rather than one innocent
suffer that is a hard question man
because i understand what you're saying
if we if we stay
if we stay with the rage and the anger
then we fall apart
but if we allow people to
get away with evil then you live in an
evil society not in the future but
for past crimes it's just an idea yeah i
think i think you'll
end up in an evil society i think when
people
when right and i don't think i don't
know if there's a real
simple solution to everything we're
seeing i mean you know it might be i
don't want to get too dark but
we saw a year of rioting we saw uh you
know i talked about this earlier
on my other channel 60 secret service
agents injured at the white house after
left-wing groups pulled down the
barricades started fires in in
in a secret service guard post and and
in the church
60 secret service officers injured and
they they they get away with it in fact
when donald trump was was brought to the
emergency bunker
because of this extreme violence the
media mocked him
and made fun of him and now you have
january 6 with those hearings today and
it's inverted completely
now the officers are crying on camera
now of course i think what happened on
january 6 when you actually watch the
footage of the violence is horrifying
and wrong and these people should be
held accountable
the problem is you have a large group of
people who see what just happened
they see 60 officers can be hurt the
president can be ushered to the bunker
and the media will laugh
but then you get you know a few hours on
one day
with another riot which is also bad and
they're holding congressional hearings
about it
this is going to shatter regular people
when they're looking at what's going on
and they're going to say i'm i'm not
playing this game anymore and what i
mean by that i think a lot of people are
going to start becoming just completely
non-compliant in the sense that they
have no confidence in the system
if someone says you know if the
government issues a mandate duex they're
going to be like why should i care
you know it's a free-for-all on this
side and nothing i'm i'm just not going
to
engage anymore this is going to lead
people to feel like the system doesn't
work
they are insecure in their in their
person and their belongings and their
family
and it's going to destabilize the
country unless there is justice
and that means by all means justice for
the people on january 6th so those
rioters who are fighting with cops and
attacking them will get charged for
their crimes
but it also means all of the riders from
the past year have to be charged and
held accountable as well
otherwise you have narco tyranny the
government will not enforce the rights
that affect the small guy and the small
businesses
they'll even ignore it when they come to
the white house and the president is
ushered downstairs
but then when it's their side they'll
enforce everything with an iron fist
that's going to shatter people yeah
the whether you like trump or not um
trump does love america he does
understand entrepreneurship
and both sides of the aisle all those
guys are on the take
you know mitch mcconnell been in office
for 30 years
he's worth 35 million pelosi's worth how
do you get 35 how do you get on
i mean so they're all trump's the only
one that's not on the take
he's only one to get rid of him and yeah
they finally did but
the the the whether you're left or right
the the people that wake up every day
and make our country great
they're just trying to make the right
decision for their families they're they
really
you know you know sometimes i get on my
i love friends both sides and i love
them both
sometimes i argue with my friends on my
left because i'm going i think your
ideology overrides your intelligence
you know because that doesn't make any
sense but it's a it's a healthy dialogue
back and forth
the progressive elite at the top will
scorch this earth
they do not care about humanity and
that's the piece that upsets me
is that i i don't think that the the
folks at the elite
progressive left top have any regard for
the
the
working man and working women they refer
to him as mouths
you know we just they just you know it's
about another mouth we got to worry
about mouths
mouths yeah another mouths we got to
worry about so wow that's that's that's
creepy
wild animals you know what i think
though i think they view it as a as it's
utilitarian
right there their whole view is if we
have a million people and
we do something that benefits 900 000
and sacrifices a hundred who cares it's
for the good of the collective
so they're willing to sacrifice the
individual not protect those rights
it's part of why centralized planning of
governance doesn't function
because they're out of touch they can't
identify with the crime
also because it foments revolutions if
you keep sacrificing different groups or
ignoring their needs because your focus
is solely on the greater collective
you end up with all of these different
organizations around you saying we're
tired of being mistreated
when you focus on the individual when
you guarantee the individual's rights
you have a whole grassroots network
moving all the way up from people who
are like i feel like my rights are being
protected
so as the progressive left starts to
gain more and more power
starts to dictate what the democrats do
you start seeing more utilitarianism
and in turn you're going to see more and
more chaos yeah yeah
i mean i think that's why they left the
leave the borders open in mexico because
those folks are going to come over
and vote left and they shut the borders
to cuba because those folks are going to
come over and say you don't want to have
what we just had for 30 years
yeah that's right hypocrisy is pretty
unbelievable in those two
border situations we saw in miami what
the pollsters were saying was safe
democrat
went republican because the people in
miami know exactly
what these words mean the people in in
south texas
are actually experiencing the problem of
the illegal immigration
but i will i will issue a a partial
clarification or partial correction
these people don't need to come and vote
left you know there's a lot of people
who say
that if you know illegal immigrants come
across the southern border
they will become citizens immediately
vote you know that's why democrats want
naturalization but the census doesn't
ask you if you're a citizen so when a
million people come across the border
this year already they can
they they can place these people in
certain areas
then on the census how many people live
here and that will affect the amount of
electoral votes
that reach that area will have i think
it was the heritage foundation said that
california gets one
extra electoral vote based on their
illegal immigration
even if these people don't vote because
they can't because they're not citizens
it still is more power in the electoral
process for these these groups
now if they do uh it's also more
congressional seats
it's not just the presidential vote you
will get a congressional seat based on
people who are not citizens
so yeah i got to come clean i've never
put
together that illegal immigration can
change the electoral vote i've never put
that together that's pretty
that's pretty interesting tim just
casually mentioned it to me like two
two a month ago and it's been like
ringing in my head ever since
well a lot of conservatives don't seem
to realize that either but you do have
the heritage foundation which mentioned
you know it's like one so it's not like
the apocalypse but hey that's a free
president yeah that's a it's a free
congressional seat so
there now i think i think california
lost the seat i'm not sure i think new
york did
uh so there are changes happening but
donald trump was trying to get the
citizenship question on the census
for this reason so that people who are
not citizens would say they're not a
citizen and then you could have better
representation for american citizens
democrats would lose a a decent amount
of power percentage-wise
if that were to happen so of course it
was blocked and thrown out
and what does that mean it means that
you could be a tax paying american
you could be born here you could follow
all the rules you got student loans you
were told to go to college you're
struggling to find work you end up as a
history major working at starbucks
you pay your taxes but you're not
getting health care
you're you you get you get sick you go
to the hospital they charge you 10 grand
you don't understand why this is
happening
unfortunately for many of these people
you have the pied piper of the
progressive left telling them the real
problem is not that they've opened the
borders
or or that they've destroyed industry
the real problem
is the industry itself so what happens
when you have people who instead of
saying hey wait a minute
maybe it's a problem that a million
people this year crossed our border
welcomed right in by joe biden i mean
that is absolutely
shocking you see these videos there's a
video that went viral a few like a week
a week ago
the border gate is open people just walk
on through walk right up to a cbp
vehicle hop on in and get taken off
now we learned there was there was a
whistleblower a two whistle blowers i
believe footage was released you know
the biden administration
is smuggling actually human trafficking
migrant children on planes into states
like tennessee
this was one of the most shocking things
i had ever seen i couldn't believe it
when you have and they're doing it out
of military base out of i believe
military bases
the binding administration is there
these are videos that have been
published
you see them taking kids putting them on
planes they flew into tennessee
and then just released them into
community centers republican politicians
they were shocked why is this happening
they are bringing they're they're giving
themselves more power
now look i got tremendous respect i say
this all the time i have
a thousand times more respect for the
illegal immigrants
who come to this country believing that
this is their opportunity for freedom
and opportunity
than i do for the progressive left that
come out and say america is evil and
racist and it's a hellscape
it's that's just not true but a system
cannot be maintained
when you have a million people just come
in economies are not
infinite bubbles of free resources
economies have
ebbs and flows they have balances
there's supply and there's demand so if
you have a massive influx of a million
workers or people looking for work
at the same time you have massive
unemployment and labor shortages
i mean you're you're adding more
problems to the mix
and we've got to solve them well you
know 1892 ellis island
that's how we all you know most of our
our
grandfathers and great grandfathers got
over here and they had a process
you know and um you know i think we we
want folks to come to america we just
want a process to
get them in and get them in legally and
i think that if we did in 1892 we should
be able to do it today
i agree yeah i often say that uh a lot
of people need to realize this too
people are critical of immigration when
the when the people immigrate here
illegally
we're getting the we are getting the
best you know these people who are
leaving nigeria and come here and
they're extremely successful
because we are getting passionate
individuals who are like i'm going to
have that dream
the challenge i suppose is the people
who are jumping the line we don't know
who they are
we don't know where they go i mean biden
is basically just shuffling them through
and dropping them off
we need to be able to make sure people
survive people flourish and that
a rising tide raises all ships i'm
thinking about vertical farming because
with this influx of people
like you said they consider the mouths
to feed have you followed like the um
like it's called the phenomena of
vertical farming like aerofarms i think
in in jersey is the largest
indoor vertical farm where they like
grow greens you can really only grow
green vegetables like leafy greens
um the the technical the roots grow
through this mesh
hanging and then you spray it with water
and nutrient water
and they get they can produce tens of
thousands of pounds of lettuce
so you're saying you think we'll be able
to feed everybody well maybe but it's
just green vegetables it's not
like did you guys ever source indoor
vertical farming food with papa john's
we looked at the organic route no way
with 5000 stores now we could done that
on a regional basis
but we had um a heck of a time
and spent over 100 million bucks a year
just getting the chemicals out of the
ingredients
that in itself was an act of god i i
want to stress something to the people
listening they may
they may be thinking themselves what is
ian talking about we're talking about
migration i was talking about farms but
it was a really good point
do we can we keep just making more and
more food
especially when there's a you you
mentioned something that's really
interesting i hear this
you're saying with 5000 stores it was
difficult to do organic trying to get
the chemicals out of the food
how do we as this this wealthy nation
support a million people coming in
you know what's funny is when it comes
to the climate change stuff they say
america is one of the biggest polluters
well then the last thing we need is a
million people coming in and adding to
that
yeah this is um this really hits home
with me
this is near and dear to my heart
because the the next whatever
next papa john's i do whatever the four
criteria it has to be in my soul
it has to be something that i breathe
and really feel
you know sacred has to be better for
humanity it has to make humanity better
i mean the pizzas was great that's good
run brings friends and family together
but
and then sustainable you don't want to
be feeding this thing and then scalable
i like big things and
one two the big problems we have in this
country is pharmaceuticals
you know they don't know the side
effects of all these drugs you know i'm
not sure they know the effects of one
when you mix two or three together
and the food supply is controlled by you
know five processors
basically and five seed companies and
they're destroying our our soil
destroying our atmosphere i mean the
organic soil is what absorbs a lot of
that co2 in the atmosphere so
monumental tests how do you how do you
get people off the pharmaceuticals
and how do you get you know get the food
supply you know back where it's at
then you go to water and then then you
go to sleep you know that's an ordering
so those are those would be the three or
four things i would want to get done
with humanity but i guess you just start
one piece at a time
and just build up like you were talking
about up in the northeast did you say
something about the ring
yeah this is an oil ring it measures
your sleep oh if you're not sleeping
good at night yeah this is
the the body recovers mentally
emotionally physically
um all your organs at night especially
when you're deep sleep so you
this moderation it's 300 bucks there's
no monthly fee
it's aura it's like a bluetooth thing
for your phone yeah you put it on it
tells you what you know
i can pull up i sleep last night oh cool
what
was it 86. i have a watch that does that
but like what am i supposed to wear my
watch in bed
that's the weirdest thing i'm like i
gotta charge it right yeah this is last
night's sleep
what does it say what what metrics does
that give you 86
sleep eight hours nine minutes 88
percent but here's what you want to look
for is your deep sleep was an hour and
43
and your rem sleep was an hour and seven
minutes wow
that's at 86. anything over even
anything over 76
is out of 100 good once you get in the
90s it's hard to do
um but this is this is really good for
sleep
and it'll give you a pulse all day you
read out your exercises i'm like
up to eighteen thousand steps today but
you're working with yeah your watch
your watch around if you want something
your your watch will do better than
this for your steps during the day your
heart rate your cycling et cetera but
this is really good for your sleep oh
wow
yeah talking about the universities you
know we were talking about the program
to teach people
free market and then they had the big
government side we we opened this
uh podcast talking about these kids who
are being indoctrinated they're being
told
they can't succeed because of their race
things like that and
i'm worried that this is going to teach
a generation
not to try they can't be successful and
will make them dependent so
you know when you're telling the story
about how you have this college program
i mean they're going to the grade
schools right now i'm curious what you
think
about you know what our kids are going
through and what do you think is going
to happen with that
i'm worried as we talked about my focus
is those four attributes
you know we talked about um and i want
it to be
under 40 because under you know between
15 and
40 this those generations um
you got processed food you got social
media
you got internet you got all this
technology you got all these technical
advices around you got pharmaceuticals
you got super high anxiety got a little
bit of deterioration of the family
i'm really worried about that
demographics and
when i hear critical race theory the law
of unintended consequences here
are you know there's going to be
tentacles going every which way
i'm worried that's actually going to
hurt the black community more than it's
going to help them
i agree there's a viral video right now
where this um
there's there's this black father and
it's i think it's actually one of the
best
criticisms of the critic of the critical
race applied principles so
theory would be just uh the academic
literature and the applied principles
would be what they actually tell the
kids and what they implement
and this is a father who says he just
very politely
says hey you know my kids came home and
they were very scared
and they said that you talked about
slavery and and
jim crow but nothing in between i'd
appreciate it
if you just you know let my kids be kids
and grow up a little bit
because i want them to be the best they
can be but they're being told they can't
so you know and that was basically it
very calm
not this rage filled how dare you is him
just being like look my kids are
freaking out and can we just let them be
kids for a minute
and then i'm like i hear you man yes
kids you what what i don't like about
what's happening in these schools and
what worries me is that
you we had the story the other day uh
fourth graders
being told to go through this critical
race you know applied principles packet
and answer all these questions
and they tell the white kids that you're
oppressors that you're evil
you know that you know you need to
recognize what you've done and your
ancestors
you know the sins of the fathers are
yours and then they tell the children
who are not white that you can't succeed
because
of your race and because of these things
what's going to happen to a kid who's
told they can't succeed
they're gonna say when they fail when
they when they stumble and fall
at their knee they're gonna look at the
crack in the ground and say that's the
fault of the white man who made the
sidewalk
not me for not paying attention if you
go through life that way
refusing to acknowledge where you have
made a mistake how could you ever
possibly improve
you can't well this whole past thing is
is a problem
um if you take uh two siblings that come
out of an alcoholic family
um one grows up and drinks themselves to
death
the other one grows up and is the ceo of
the president
or whatever to fortune and fame and
so you you ask the one that eventually
drank them so why well why'd you why'd
you drink somebody he said well
because my parents drink all the time
and then you ask the other sibling that
went to the top
why why didn't you drink and they said
well i didn't drink because my parents
drank and i want to be like my parents
the point of that is the the past
doesn't make the future
the future makes the past this living in
the past
you know you got to acknowledge it you
got to learn from it
but we can't be worrying about things
that happen you know two three four five
six hundred years ago we need to
identify what's going on right now
and plan for a bright future for all of
us
yeah i think there's a lot of powerful
political interests who recognize
grievances make money media outlets
realize
hey if we can say something that's
shocking and and freak people out
we're gonna get paid and then their
special political interests say we will
get votes
whether it's votes or cash there's power
to be had in in fanning the flames of
this stuff
well there's money everywhere that's you
know the medical
system academia i mean it's just a big
money machine the pharmaceuticals we
talked about the big is they give in
lobbyists the food processor
so all of it is gets back to you know
follow the money
for sure but there's at the end of the
day principles
always are more powerful than force and
good
is always supersedes evil we just got to
hang on to it
there are just some bad people who think
i think it's a lack of empathy
in a sense they don't care what happens
to other people perhaps it's a
combination of utilitarianism and
nihilism or callousness or some measure
of each you know
individual idea existing within people
one of my favorite stories i tell people
is this
back when i was uh you know growing up
in chicago there was there were people
who would you know sell pot right
and it was like a really risky thing to
do you know what i mean you might make
money doing it but it's super illegal
and i remember meeting some guy and he
was talking about how people were really
dumb he's like man you got people in
this neighborhood they're so stupid you
know why they sell they sell dope
they're selling pot why would you do
that
and then i was like what do you mean
they're trying to make money it's like
an easy way to make money he's like no
it isn't
he's like you know what i do he's like i
call local venues i
ask them what bands are playing this
weekend friday or saturday
i call the band and say hey i'm gonna
make shirts for you to sell to your
audience and i'll take 20 percent
and they'd say okay and then you go to a
print shop he'd spend
you know a couple hundred bucks on
shirts sell them all out to this band's
fans make himself a couple grand in a
weekend totally legally
and he was like i make more money
working one day out of the week than all
of these people selling dope why are
they doing it they're not thinking
they're being told lies they're being
told it's easy waiting money is not true
man
there's better ways to make money so i
bring this up because there's a lot of
people
who are grifting who are manipulating
who are trying to make a quick buck
what there's really easy ways to make
legitimate money if you just think and
you work hard
well you know back to this board of
directors i mean you can talk about what
they did
evil they said you know the other and
just how wrong and it's horrific
but it's it's their problem it's not my
problem all i can do every day
is wake up and and put the best version
of jon forward that i can put forward as
long as i'm better
myself and i'm better than the people
around me then hopefully that'll spread
a lot a lot better and a lot more
poignant and a lot more graceful than
people that are doing wrong
i do i believe that so when when uh uh
you're
we had people from your crew show up we
also had a bunch of free
you sent us some pizzas right so we're
downstairs and papa john's pizza shows
up
i was told by uh some of the people who
are working with you that you can they
were like oh send him a picture he will
point out
everything that's wrong with the pizzas
and at first i was like do you mean like
the the since he left they've ruined the
pizzas no no just like
the pizzas aren't perfect right so so
actually one of the first things you do
is you come in you're like let me take a
look
and then you pointed out you know here's
where they made mistakes this should
have done this they should have been
better
i only bring this up because you
mentioned there was a bonus thing that
you had
that you were you are paying out a
decent amount of the profits and bonuses
to your staff that was
that that's true right well the guest
experience
can't uh exceed the um the
employees experience and the employees
have a miserable day of work
they're going to take it out on the
guest so we always put the employees
first
and a big part of that was we made them
feel like owners and we did that through
profit sharing
and if you got the product right and you
got the service right you had a good
attitude usually the customer was pretty
happy so we we figured out how to
measure that
we put out a great pizza and when they
got it right and they get with good
service and good attitude then we paid
in bonuses in the tens of millions of
dollars
so our employees not only were they
getting promotions and getting raises
they were getting huge
bonuses and so that was what i call a
win-win win win win
was there a percentage that you
allocated to this well the managers for
st
for example are 20 percent but it goes
right up from
the manager right up the supervisor
right up even the people in the office
the executives all get paid it's another
thing we did we had the bonus system
aligned
from top to bottom so most corporations
the guy not only at the top gets his
four five six seven million bucks and
the people at the bottom getting taken
advantage of which is immoral
it's unethical um we made it so that
the guy at the top couldn't get a bonus
unless the folks doing the heavy lifting
at store level got a bonus so the bonus
system had a total alignment total
integrity and that was very that was one
of the most powerful things we did is
bonus from bottom to top it does that
that system still exists after you've
left
no the first two things they did when i
left was
they took out the measurement system so
if you don't measure it they're not
going to do it
if you don't reward that measurement
measurement meant the quality of what
you just alluded to the 10 point scale
and the quad of the product
how long it took to get the pizza there
how many times the phone ring did the
driver had had on did the driver smile
that kind of thing
the measurement system the matrix to
measure the quality and what we call
demonstrable value which is basically
the customer experience and the second
thing they took out was
the principles we really are big on
principles
and we think we got to have core values
every company has
core values fedex is going to have
different core values then gm
gm is going to have different core
values than papa john's core values are
nice
and they're pretty um
you know specific to whatever company
but principles are universal
so mutual respect kindness
thoughtfulness collaborative alliances
win win win
authenticity those are all like gravity
they're just there
and you can fight principles all you
want but principles like gravity sooner
or later are
going to win so we built the company on
principles
and then core values and then
measurement system on quality
and it was very very powerful but that's
the things they took out the first
because those are the hardest things to
do
how did it start well real quick though
to follow this point the reason i
brought this up is that bernie sanders
proposed 20 stock sharing with
with the workers so that when profits
come in a quarter of the profits are
divvied up and then sent out to the
workers
it's fascinating to me that you know
i've heard uh quotes from you about
minimum wage being too low
we you're talking now about this bonus
structure and it sounds like a lot of
things the left claims to want
you are actually doing chick-fil-a gives
half the money to their managers half
the profits go to the store manager so
i'm i'm big on ownership and i'm big on
splitting the pie up
um if you give the employees a say
you're making
a hundred thousand bucks a year and you
give employees 30
000 of it um you know believe it or not
within a year or two they're going to
have that number up to 140 or 160. yeah
so you want to make money i know and so
that 70 percent
of a hundred exactly if you had 100 100
within two or three years
the seventy percent of the number is
going to be bigger numbers so yeah it
compounds itself for sure
chick-fil-a they pay their staff really
well also right they do everything well
i mean there's a
they're they're um principle-centered i
don't like to get too much into
religion but they're definitely
spiritual um you know they
they obey universal laws and universal
truths
uh they're very consistent they're
family run so they can do
they can play the long game and um they
take care of their people and they love
uh they love america and they love
humanity they're they're
they were the one company that we always
wanted to be like chick-fil-a yeah
wow in the very beginning when you spun
up papa john's you had one
restaurant yes what year was that broom
closet was 84.
the first freestanding building was
1985. and you had did you let
the principal hold on broom closet yeah
we were in the brew closet of the
the old man's tavern nice five dollar
pizzas in the broom closet 50 cent beers
in the front and a dollar big burger on
the side
was it like the similar ingredients as
to what you used as the years went on or
did you kind of tweak the
we always we always really did have good
integrity with ingredients we
didn't have the ingredients um when we
started off with that we had when i left
in 18 because we didn't have the money
to
you know to get rid of all the chemicals
and some of the other things but we had
the fresh back sauce
we ground their own cheese we had the
monster mozzarella blend
um we made our own dough so it was it
was a good pie from the
did you freeze how old were you in the
room like
we'll start from the broom closet how
old were you when you were doing this
broom closet in the tavern
vroom closet was 84 so i would have been
22.
22. so you started making pizzas as part
of this tavern how did that become a
freestanding building
we're in the broom closet and um
we're in there for a couple months and
we're we're doing well in the bar we're
selling 50 cent beers
and we're doing these dollar mick
burgers and we're doing real well and so
we started selling these five hour
pizzas on the back and
you know we do 10 a day and then we do a
hundred dollars so one tuesday
we did 200 bucks on a tuesday in this
broom closet my brother and i were
jumping up and down
because we thought we were rich and uh
when i left we'd do
20 million dollars a day and couldn't
pay our bills but anyway
but we really thought 200 bucks you know
how in the world can you spend all that
money
and then we got that broom closet up to
about three thousand dollars
and so we there was an old kfc original
kfc in jeffersonville was
adjacent to mixed lounge so we actually
took that space over
and built a dining room a big kitchen
and built a freestanding building
right next to mick's lounge the business
went from 3 000 a week to 9 000 in two
weeks
wow and i went heck didn't cuss
heck if you put a sign on the front door
it really helps your marketing
so we didn't have a sign on the front
door so we tripled our business by just
putting a papa john's sign on the front
door was that
you said three thousand and nine
thousand was that after expenditures of
the new place like rent rent that was
just sales weekly sales
we tripled our sales you do everything
off your sales in the restaurant
business
no no no hold on there a minute you said
it was called papa john's
right away and it was named after you
uh-huh and how old are you 22
22. you were not a father were you no
it's a it's all
it's all it's all built on a lie isn't
it well you don't have to be friends to
be a good lover
yeah they told me to put equity on my uh
on my resume when i was an actor
non-equity and they're like this way
you'll get hired in equity because they
think you're already equity and then
when they hire you they'll actually
pay for you to become equity hey there
you go yeah age old reasoning so so
let's let's walk through this then so
you got one store
uh 9 000 a week you said when was there
a moment where you realized that it was
taken off and you were gonna be
uh very successful we're doing 9 000 a
week
and there's a dominoes about two miles
down the road in grant plaza
so i drive down and you understand i'm
i'm 22
i'm pumped you know we're killing it
mixed we're killing it with the beer
killing it with the pool tables killing
with a mcburger now we're killing it
with pizza so we're having a big time
we're 22 23 years old in jeffersonville
indiana making 130 grand a year
wow selling five dollar pizzas and 50
beers i walk in these dominoes and i
look at the manager and i said
what are you doing a week he said yeah
i'm doing i'm doing five
five fifty five six thousand a week and
i looked at him
and so we're doing nine thousand and i
turned around and walked out of the
dominoes and i thought if i can beat
them in jerusalem in the end i can beat
them in the whole world
wow i'm 20 but this time we had our own
building this had been 85 so i'd have
been 23.
i'm 23 years old and i thought like that
i thought
we can only we can we can we can rule
the world
we can beat them and down we can roll
the pizza away i know we thought that
way
i mean i look back and i go man i really
was crazy
you did it well so so yeah walk us
through where where you end up what was
your second location how did that how
did that come to be well the first store
had
um in-house dining mozzarella sticks
zucchini salads mug of beer if you
wanted it
and the consumers didn't like the dining
room they liked it delivered
and the dining room was all the expense
and the capital outlay
so the second store we went to the
formula put a hundred thousand
in to build it do ten thousand a week in
sales make ten percent profits with a
thousand dollar month rent
and that formula got us to about store
20 or 25 which would have been 18
1989 1990 and then from there we just
kept getting a little bit better and
kept growing that top line and then
as i said went public in june of 93. did
uh did domino's have a dining room too
no no so you you were actually starting
off as like a traditional neighborhood
pizza restaurant or italian restaurant i
guess
well you always have to listen to the
customer you know that's like marketing
everybody's a marketing genius because
but the problem with that is it's inside
out thinking
you don't need to think about marketing
from inside out you need to think about
it from the customer's perspective from
the prospects
perspective and so the customer was
telling us they like our pizza delivered
they want it carried out and delivered
they don't want to sit down and eat it
at the store so you got to listen to
your customer and so we did we got rid
of
the dining room what was like the
ingredient sourcing experience like
from the first restaurant on how did you
start advancing them
well we knew what sauce we wanted um we
had the recipes on the dough
we knew how to grind the cheese from the
from the very beginning yeah cause i've
made pizzas at rockies when i was 15.
i'd worked at greek's pizzeria worked at
domino's
we were familiar with crawls bakery and
some of their baking techniques so we
had a pretty good formula for the pizza
early on
and we just we just ran we went around
and took the best from from everybody
the best sauce the best cheese the best
box the best whatever
and took all that and combined it into
it so we basically stole all the best
recipes ingredients ideas from all the
competition and just tried to combine it
into one concept
garlic sauce was pretty great breaking
because nobody really a lot of other
restaurants i don't think they did that
did they
no we um there was an independent
pizzeria over in new albany
and they had the garlic sauce and i just
thought that was a neat idea to put the
salt the
dough in the garlic sauce to the you
know the crust and dip it
and so we started that and we got what
we did we took um
butter and put it in a tube um heated it
up
took the tube and then filled these
little cups up and the problem is that
butter would go everywhere the whole
store would be slick with butter
so store number three we took the butter
out
and the consumer went crazy i want my
butter i want butter so
we were forced to put so um the big
thing with the butter is how do you
manufacture that butter
and get that lid to stay on and so that
was a patent to get that done
and so when we finally left we were
selling a million pizzas a day
and so those butters are like eight
cents a piece so
our butter bill was i don't know 30
million bucks a year that was a crazy
number
eight cents to manchester crazy number
what it was in 2018
well let's run the math so we know we're
selling over 300 million pizzas a year
and we know that those butters i think
those butters are 10 cents it's been a
while so it's
that's that's 30 million bucks on
butters but i mean
that's going to be a ballpark now that
may be a little old but that's going to
be close i would imagine they enhanced
the value of the pizza by 30
that maybe is a large number maybe
fifteen percent yeah but i mean
ten cents for twenty percent the butter
the butters and the pepperoncinis were
just kind of our ways way to say thank
you
this is interesting pepperoncinis are
actually growing in the backyard in
greece
little farmers they put the little pails
out and people come by and pick them up
and we started putting a couple
pepperoncinis in every box
and it got to be 1996 97 and there was a
shortage on pepperoncinis
the price of pepperonis per bushel went
up four fold
because we were using too too many
pepperoni but i i love that
you know the best part you get the
garlic the garlic was it the garlic
butter sauce and the pepperoncinis
garlic butter i always i always ask for
extra peppers man i love them
you don't have the pizza i have to ask
i'm being pressured to ask this by
outside sources
what happened with putting soy into your
pizza i guess there was some
conversation about that going back a
couple years i guess
i don't really know i'm really not
really up to date on soy um
the some of the some of the oils that we
use on the dough machines
could be soybean soy soybean based um
but i don't know if there's a lot of
soybeans soybeans used for fillers we
didn't use a lot of fillers if any
okay but remember it's been five years
since i've been in there so i'm not sure
what they're putting in it
interesting so uh let's uh
because we do hard-hitting journalism
here at timcast.com we're gonna i want i
wanna i
actually wanna pull up these ingredients
uh domino's pizza hut and papa john's
and you know so your slogan was better
ingredients better pizza
there we we order pizza all the time we
got a ton of people working here now
it's it's growing by the day and so i
frequently just try and get everybody
some food we bring it in and we have
these sit down meetings kind of things
we do
everybody sits down it's like a family
dinner but for the for the staff
and so we'll do pizza we've ordered
pizza before i won't order pizza ever
again
i looked up their ingredients i want to
show people something it's interesting
to me
we got the ingredients from dominos.com
i just googled this all right
i got their brooklyn their handmade
pancreas their hand tossed crust because
again hard-hitting journalism right this
is the stuff you
you guys really want to know about i
look at their their their hand-tossed
crust and it's got like
you know maltodextrin uh it's got dough
conditioners
sodium sterile acetate
enzyme calcium sulfate ascorbic acid
vitamin c which is which is vitamin c
calcium phosphate l-cysteine yeast
cornmeal
they mention they break down what
enriched flour is and what's in it so
folic acid like that
but i i noticed there's there's these
dough conditioners don't know what that
is
that's potassium bromate but they're not
calling a potassium bromide anymore
because it's
they use it in yoga mats what yeah it's
a chemical that's in yoga mats that they
put in bread as a
as a treatment well hold in europe let
me pull out
pull up the weirdest thing because i
looked at it i looked up pizza right so
this is
nutritionix.com pizza ingredient search
maybe this is wrong
because it's not pizza.com but they say
in their crust
they do enriched flour then they say
okay so where's that end okay water
yeast soybean oil
and then it contains vital wheat gluten
sugar and
sugar enzymes ascorbic acid sucralose
pan oil soybean oil tbhq added to
protect freshness
sucralose is splenda it's an artificial
sweetener they're putting a fake
artificial i don't i don't i don't like
drinking that stuff i don't like eating
it that was really weird to me
and then i look up uh papa john's and
it's it's unbleached and rich wheat
flour so
that's used by the other ones enriched
and then it says sugar soybean oil salt
yeast
the ingredients list on papa john's it's
like the soybean oil
that's what i want to ask i've been
using olive oil that's that's why i just
had to bring this up because lady acid
when i did love we did have olive oil on
the dough that was one thing they took
out
um and it it it didn't have 100 olive
oil but we did put olive oil in and
they didn't um it was one of the things
the corners they cut but i'm delighted
they didn't
hear they didn't cut more because
remember this is now run for wall street
this thing's run for
eps this is not run for the employees or
for the team members or for the quality
of the product so
they're if they're doing if they're
staying pretty clear with this
um pretty clean with this that's a
that's a real good thing to uphold that
better ingredients better pizza
promise but did you always have soybean
oil in it we always had soybean
though or canola oil in the in the sauce
we always had sauce
yeah did you use different oils in the
sauce oh yeah the the sauce uses olive
oil
olive oils oils are tough um and they're
they're that's one of the things that
you get what you pay for
um uh the better the better quality oil
the
more cost more money cost the the garlic
butter
um you can really cheat on the garlic
butter and use a cheaper oil
but i think it really hurts the quality
yeah for sure but again i've been out of
the system for five years i'm not
exactly sure
do you make pizza at the house now oh
yeah i got a pizza oven oh like a brick
oven
um i got an oven from the roman empire
columns from the roman empire 300 a.d
yeah so you come over next time you're
on louisville come over i'll make you
some papa john's
we should rock i love making pizza from
scratch you can do it all from scratch
now do you make the get the tomatoes
i usually go up to papa john's and get
some dough balls
and you get some dough and some sauce
then go back it's a wood burning
uh really heavy metal um kind of outdoor
oven
you know it's not the conveyor of it but
it makes a pretty mean pie would they do
wood burning at papa john's while you
were there did you just use conventional
ovens
we played with that but our volumes we
needed a you know we needed a conveyor
oven just because of the volumes but
i'll give you an ingredient story we
went to hutchinson kansas to look at
sausage of beef
and when i went to the factory because i
eat sausage john's favorites pepperoni
sausage six cheese
i was appalled to what they were putting
in the sausage the hoof of the cow
the face of the cow it was bad and i
said no no no
i want and we at the time probably had
six seven hundred stores
i said well no that's just the way we do
it i go it's not the way i'm gonna do it
we're gonna have the you know the
tenderloin the good part of it i had to
wrestle with them for three or four
months and we were spending a lot of
money
to get them to get all the chemicals out
and to use
you know the best uh best parts of the
cow and the pig
uh you know to make make that make the
make the product
and that took it took you know some real
doing so
um when we hired kids out of college
these uh food scientists
we tried to get them to learn how to
take chemicals out and what you were
just reading on that list these kids
have been taught how to add stuff
and they looked at me like i was crazy i
said you know you
we need to get this stuff out of here
because no idea what it's doing to your
stomach and
your evolutionary part of our system
that doesn't know how to deal with all
these chemicals
and we lost a lot of food scientists
because they like
putting stuff in they like putting all
those chemicals in and
being kind of a witch's brew of
chemicals to make up you know taste or
you know to extend the product whatever
and we said no we like to keep things
real simple and if i can't read it and
two or three
you know four ingredients per ingredient
and i can't pronounce it then i don't
want it in the product and that that
took some doing and that was over a
hundred million bucks a year when i left
i don't know if they're still doing it
well they would spend in it to get the
stuff out it was over over a hundred
million bucks to
walk i thought so now there's two ways
to look at this
one is you want to keep the integrity of
the better ingredients better pizza
promise
uh alive and well and healthy by walking
the talk and walking the talk cost a lot
of money
the flip of that is processed foods may
be addictive
so we may be actually putting something
in the product that wasn't as addictive
as if you put the stuff in there so we
we never got around to figuring out
were people eating less papa john's
because it didn't have chemicals in it
it wasn't addictive
that was a trade-off that we uh we look
familiar with social media they have
like slot machines where like they make
you addicted to these social media
platforms
and you want to get the likes and yeah
you know what you know what you know
what scares me man
is that uh dave thomas wendy's he was
very much a better ingredient
kind of guy or at least that's that's
the way i remember i was a little kid i
remember going to wendy's and had a
salad bar
but as soon as dave thomas passes it
goes wall street right
they wanna they wanna make the profits
crank the profits up crank the margins
up
cut costs cut corners and then you end
up with
worse ingredients worse burgers right
well
take kfc kfc's got a head one time great
fried chicken
average kfc does about a million two in
volume the average chick-fil-a does five
man
so when you start running the business
for wall street you can have some
short-term success
but in the pizza category in particular
it's so hyper-competitive that if you're
playing games with product quality
and not really taking care of your your
employees and sooner or later it's going
to catch up with you pretty quick
i worked at wendy's in 1980 when we used
to patty the beef in the back and do
everything by scratch please i'm sorry
especially with bread i mean if you eat
a bread with a with a preservative in it
you know
it stays in your system if you eat a
pure bread flour water sugar yeast
maybe some salt well definitely some
salt it like passes through you almost
like water like it's
your body i don't know if that's a good
thing you can eat so
much more organic uh bread without you
don't feel bad preservatives
exactly you know i'll tell you this uh
remember that popeye's chicken sandwich
thing they were trying to claim it was
the greatest thing ever
i had there are people on social media
being like wow it's better than
chick-fil-a and i was like how's that
possible
i went to popeye's i got the sandwich i
did not like it i thought it was bad
uh it was it was a chicken sandwich
right i don't wanna say it was bad but
chick-fil-a is really
really good and you know whenever
whenever whenever we go to chick-fil-a
it's the service is great people are
working really hard everything is is
clean and set up properly and
it's just like it's a it's a well-oiled
machine and the food is always really
it's always fantastic yeah that's the
kathy family um it was true
and he passed away a few years back and
then stan and
bubba in the in the family they just do
a tremendous job but this
this processed food i mean they're 99.9
of the american population has a
chemical addiction it's called processed
food
and this processed food is very
dangerous and we're going to have to get
our arms around it because it's
a big culprit in all the some of the
most prevalent
and outrageous health issues we're
having with our country
i heard this it may be apocryphal but i
heard that
after colonel sanders like franchised
out and sold he went back to uh he went
to go try the new you know kfc and he
said it was awful and disgusting or
something like that
maybe that's not true i read that
somewhere on the internet i had
something in the
in the garlic butter at papa johnson it
was i don't know if it's a different
recipe than it used to be but it was
hard harder to digest than i remember it
being i got sugar out of my diet though
that's good yeah good
sugar the sugar is probably worse than
anything even the caffeine and alcohol
the sugar is pretty deadly but yeah
the colonel was fanatical about his
chicken yeah you know he was funny he
was
fanatical and finicky about and quirky
about how he wanted that chicken cooked
have you been like marinating any new
recipes
for other types of foods and no you just
work at home just have fun with it just
fun i got i got an organic garden i play
with
i would i would you know when you came
in and you were looking at the pizzas
that was that were made by the local
papa john's and you're like oh see
there's a problem you're like pointing
the crust
i'm like man a pizza made by you must be
the best pizza
that'd be fun we should have a pizza
making contest
i would love to come to the house we'll
yes we'll do it with the roman empire
columns with the pizza nice
but um the first six months in the broom
closet
i was convinced i was the only one that
could make a pizza right
and so i made every single pizza and
that got old and so
um but that was kind of funny but no
there's plenty of folks
there's great pizza makers of papa
john's and there's a lot of them that
can make a better pizza than i can but
i do like making pizza so you had to
learn how to trust other people to make
your
ingredients similar to what tim's doing
with the tim cast brand he's letting
other people create
shows on the network was it like what
was that like
it's like letting somebody watch your
child
you know i could only imagine a mother
um
you know dropping or newborn off
you know you know four five six months
into the grandparents even i mean you
just you know
when it's your baby it's sacred so it
was hard it was hard not to make every
pizza and not worry about
every pizza what'd you do have someone
make one and you tasted it and you're
like oh yeah good enough close enough
it's
i can't tell probably wasn't quite that
nice it was probably like you didn't
make it right let's start over
let's do it let's get this right you
know with growing this business
there's a lot of like ideas i have for
the figurative pizza which is
the content we'll be producing and it
gets to a point where
you know i'm going to go i'm talking to
some of the new staff like here's my
vision here's what i think
then they go off and do it then i got
then i've got to see the product and say
okay here's my notes on it
and i i definitely think
you know maybe this is a bit arrogant
but if i was the one
always doing everything it would be you
know top tier a plus plus
but it's impossible it's not possible to
be
doing every single aspect you need to
have
people who who can take that load off
who can start expanding the business
and you've got to do your best to find
the talent and the drive and the passion
for people who want to do it and do it
right
can only imagine going to 5 000 stores
is i could i couldn't even imagine that
right now
well what's the saying if the captain of
the ship has to be the captain of the
ship he's really not a good captain
a good captain has plenty of people
around him that can run the ship just as
good as he can
your the issue god is you have the
producer the manager the supervisor and
the leader
sorry brother you're the producer you
you're the one that makes the food i
mean you're the one that's got you so
you
you're stuck there and then you're gonna
have to be the leader but the manager
and the supervision roles in between
right that's something you could fill in
but you're always gonna be the guy
making the pizza you're always going to
be the guy
in front of the mic you just need to get
other folks to do these other peripheral
leadership capabilities maybe you know
maybe once the
the we launch enough other shows you
know i'll be pushed into the back
and uh maybe just you know look you know
you made your pizzas for some time and
then you eventually were just running
the company but you still knew how to
make the pizzas
i definitely think there will come a
time where
you know i i think even with the next
five years or so it's gonna be
impossible for me
for to do four hours per day of
podcasting
it'll be impossible and first of all my
throat's gonna explode
but also it's just if if this is gonna
be something bigger better more
important if we're gonna be building
culture
then my talents are better served
helping other people
start filling that role in expanding and
helping make those changes
inspiring people and having fun and
making that content
it'll probably i'll probably better off
doing that so
you know one of the things i used to
work on saturday and sundays i used to
actually do podcast recordings i decided
to pull that back and focus on the vlog
and now it's much more relaxing
but it gives me more time so i reduced
the amount of content i did per day as
well i used to do
three additional segments which totaled
about 50 minutes cut that out
so i'd have time to go to the bank to
file paperwork to deal with legal stuff
otherwise the company couldn't grow yeah
so i i'd actually back away from
making pizzas figuratively and you know
to do the business you know if i was you
i would i would do the things that only
you can do
you don't have a choice then there's the
next column up that's the things that
you could um
you could do but somebody else could
also do um and
that's your call whether you do it or
not if you know and the third one is
there's things
you could maybe do but you shouldn't be
doing you really need somebody else to
do it and so
i think you pick the parts you love
you're not gonna be able to i mean you
gotta hear this morning at 8 30 9
o'clock
and we're going to get out of this thing
at 11. you can't keep doing that you
know you'll just burn out so you got to
find the parts of this
gig that you love and the time you want
to do it
and um you know find the time find the
thing you love and just work it to the
bone but
you know it's got to be the things you
want to do right right
my opinion yeah so you know that i've
got two different formats for the shows
that we do here we've got
this which is the conversation the
interviews and we talk about news and
stuff that's tim cast irl
and then i've got my two other channels
which are fairly similar which is me
sort of
you know monologuing right that's the
segment that you saw when i talked about
your issue in 2018 the circumstances
around what happened to you
and i really do think that in the next
few years this
is going to be what ultimately survives
and carries on
something that uh is
longer more in depth i think
you know a lot of people have told me
they like the the in-depth breakdowns
that i do
you know personally but uh i gotta i
gotta figure out a way to
to empower more people to this idea of
freedom
individual responsibility the free
market stuff to a certain extent i
wouldn't consider myself a lot
of fair capitalist we've got to figure
out how to grow that and so what i'm
trying to say is
it'll probably come a time in a few
years where those other channels take a
a back seat
and this becomes the the primary
flagship or whatever but that's only
going to be because we'll have 100 200
employees producing movies documentaries
other podcasts and just have this
massive network
and i'm going to have to do quality
control basically so
you know i could make a mean figurative
podcast pizza
or i can teach people how to make you
know and then oversee and make sure
they're all doing it right and we grow
that business
well you know just just one um
one meeting with you and and you know
two observations
remember i did not see this board of
directors doing what they did i did not
have that awareness i think your gift is
you have
an acute ability to really
be able to cut through things and really
get to the heart of what's going on real
quick
and you do it in a way that's actually
very congenial it's very you know it's
very nice
which is most guys that are that sharp
usually are pretty
poignant with their bite but i think
you've got a a great way of just
cutting through the nonsense and getting
right to the meat of the matter
that's going to be a tough attribute to
replace that's a gift that's really a
gift from god
it is but i also think that you know
i've made mistakes i've trusted people i
shouldn't trust
i've i've dealt with business it is it
is not easy you know it's what's
fascinating is the things i've already
dealt with
in trying to run and start business the
board of directors thing you didn't see
coming but i have to imagine that
you know throughout your your career you
had a ton
of beef and problems and you know
complaints and threats of lawsuits
well good judgment comes from bad
judgment and bad judgment comes from bad
experience
yeah so it's just that comes it just you
know
again the longer i live the less i know
i know i mean it just
if just when you think you're on top of
life and you got it figured out it's
like raising kids i mean just you'd like
you're just not quite as good at it as
you thought you were you know just
there's always something coming from
somewhere and that's just what makes
life so interesting
let's take some super chats talk to the
audience see they got they got a lot of
questions for you and a lot of positive
statements it seems
uh if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and go to timcast.com become a member
we'll have a bonus segment coming up
just after
the show usually usually was around 11
or so p.m all right
um clayton pahuna says i ate 40 pizzas
in the last 30 days
is that true did you eat 40 pizzas in 30
days no
i didn't say i who's this by the way
it's just a user clayton
where's do you get to ask him where he's
from or no no so they just
they comment and we get a list of their
their chats hey clayton
um a little bit um word trickery there
it doesn't say i ate 40 50 pizzas in 30
days
it said i had um 50 pizzas in 30
days what we do is we have a system that
i mentioned earlier the measurement
system
where we have secret shoppers and we
order um
pizzas and we own enough that we know
through a bell-shaped curve with
standard deviation who's doing what so
we get enough orders i think in the last
last nine months i've ordered about 900
papa john pizzas because
i own stock and i kind of watch what
they're doing so i want to know what
they're doing
and as you saw earlier i can look at the
pizza and tell you if they're doing it
right or not
so um we didn't eat 50 pizzas in 30 days
but we did have 200 pizzas in two months
wow wow but you sampled um
sampled it looked at oh okay maybe took
a bite out of everything and the media
spins it to make it seem like you're
saying they're just guzzling faces
we got a lot of publicity off of it it
just wasn't true
rainer chen says ten dollars in honor of
papa john maybe use it to buy pizza hut
for later
papa john i'm a big fan love the whopper
by the way
what mix it all in there wow now here's
the important question
kyle miller says john do you still have
your z28 camaro
i do um i um i bought that car when i
was 15 washing
dishes rocky subpuff for 1 600 bucks
uh i sold it october of 83
for 2800 to get daddy out of bankruptcy
and then i bought it back in 2009 for
275 000. i'm
not a very good hog swapper here so
don't go in business with me i'll
you know i'm not not making any money
but yeah we um i have that in a vault
in the basement of my house wow the
original car that is an awesome story
yeah you had to sell it to help out your
family is that what happened yeah old
man was banked
bankrupt and mixed lounge and we sold it
for 2 800 to get a
load of beer to get us through the
weekend it's funny that in 83
2800 was more valuable than 150
000 or whatever it was in 2008 like it's
so relative
money the amount of money you have and
use um
well they um they had a sucker on the
line that wanted the car
me does it still drive
oh yeah it's fast it's 150 560 mile it's
an eight two eight three quarter mile
car yeah it's it's a it's a
it's a bad car it's it's and when you
come over to make pizzas at the house
uh i'll take you for ride in the car and
show you i'll show you my
26 car museum that really only has three
cars
i don't have a 26 they always say i have
a 26 car museum in my basement it's
three cars so
are you getting more all right no that's
all the hulk all right release the
crackle says
heart your pizza the name's ben was my
birthday the other day would you make my
would make my year to have a quote have
a papa blessed day from you papa john
for president 2024
and this is who this is release the
crackle that's that's the release the
question
his name's ben ben yeah his name's ben
and he would love for you to say have a
papa blessed day
ben we love you papa john's have a papa
blessed day
happy birthday all right let's see
curious mishap says yo papa john my
second job ever was at a papa john's in
2014 legit my favorite pizza i'm
actually a fan thank you for being the
best you're my inspiration
well thank you for that i appreciate
that and you're my inspiration you're
the ones that make papa john's great
every day so thank you
all right let's see
dark soul says hey papa my boss just got
fired for private text messages the
company is crazy now been there for two
years and it's just trash
well hang in there with them i'm not
happy with them right now and
i just you know we had two fundamental
principles uh when we started out and
that is
take care of our people be good to our
employees our team members they're
what makes papa john's great and take
care of our product and
last couple years i feel like we lost
our way with those two attributes but
i'm pounding on the board of directors
pretty hard they know how i feel about
this
and um you know like i say it's my name
on the door
it's my recipe and i found it and
hopefully
sooner or later they'll they'll listen
to me right now with colvin
and all these xx dollars excess dollars
they they can't do anything wrong the
phone rings off the hook
regardless how good the pizza is and so
but sooner or later
you know you know our luck's going to
run out and we're going to have to get
back to serving good pizza with good
service so
i'm pushing pretty hard but i'm sorry to
hear that and um it was
was it her dad that got fired his boss
her boss yeah
uh ca foe says pj employee here nice to
see the papa on your show tim
i can confirm the recipes have been
changed since he left to cut some costs
yeah again you can't make a silk purse
out of the sauce there
i mean if you want you know it's garbage
and garbage out i mean
i've not figured out how to get quality
or authenticity or superiority without
paying for it i just haven't figured out
you know how you get something really
good at the end if you don't start off
with really something good in the
beginning so i'm sorry to hear that that
was my
as you can imagine of being a founder
and having your name on the door
um i'll never box um when i hear those
kind of stories i get
it's it's upsetting it's like you're in
the quality control that you were
talking about earlier
yeah you know the same garbage in
garbage out you always got to make sure
you got better ingredients if you want
to make a better pizza
better ingredients better pizza you got
it tim
uh so i just want to say before i read
this next one welcome to the internet
um mk90 says the banished one returns
once again in an attempt to out pizza
the hut all hail the father lord
jonathan he shall sit upon the sun
throne praise the sun
uh a lot of people are i think you know
a lot of people probably became fans
when they realized that they were they
were steamrolling you and they were
coming after you and it was unjust
so a lot of people were probably just
you know they looked into your story
they learned about
your you how you how you treat your
employees they learned about your story
with your car and they're like here's a
guy who works hard was successful
and boy did they they screw you over i'd
say boycott these
no good you know whats but the problem
is i love the franchisees
i mean if it was just these corporate
you know
bank robbers you know these folks that
are just out for the money i'd say let's
boycott papa john's until they get back
to
taking care of their employees and take
care of the product but i can't do that
because i love the franchisees and
they're the small business owners at the
interface so
if i could if i could say boycott all
the corporate markets
um you know um then you know
that may be a go but right now we can't
say boycott papa john's
even though the products slipped and the
concern and the
the love for the employees that slipped
because it will hurt the franchisees and
i would never do anything to hurt the
franchisee is there a situation where if
the corporate wanted to change the
ingredients to something terrible that
the franchisees could override that and
say
we're going to use this at this
restaurant
um no they could be
pretty reverse about it and uh
boisterous
but you understand the franchisees are
probably gonna want to go along with the
cheaper ingredients because they'll make
more money short term so
franchisees are probably a little bit
more looking at the
the finances and the economics whereas
the founder
looks at it from the spirit and the soul
the brand from the authenticity and the
quality and the passion for doing it
first class so
that's why i like i like a business like
papa john's we
we we were public we were big we had
scale
you know it's not that's a good thing
but we ran it like a family-owned
business with regard to people and
product
um and i think i like the balance of
those two
you have to have professional management
you want to run things tight but you
also
want to have that human touch in there
this is interesting manifest
manifested destiny says i will always
believe john got railroaded because he
outed the criminal mob running the
university of louisville
he messed with the corrupt louisville
establishment that still hasn't faced
any charges
is that true what happened with that
amen sister she she nailed that
yeah we we got rid of uh we cleaned
there was there was a three-legged stool
which is really a four but
three the three-legged stool on the
university of louisville and it was
corrupt was the board of trustees
we had to get rid of that was the
athletic department
we had to get rid of all those folks
they were paying athletes big money to
come to louisville
and then the foundation which they
embezzled money out of so we finished
finished all three of those then what
she's referring to is
the next was the faculty uh the faculty
has tenure and you can't fire them right
and no matter what they do you can't
fire them and we were going to put a
stop to that
and make sure that we're we're here for
the kids
and we're here to better their education
we're not here
so that you can make 200 000 a year and
go to italy you know every other year so
um they we ruffled a lot of feathers
trying to clean that university up
myself david grissom and we had a great
board of trustees we worked hard on that
for about two and a half years
but remember we're hitting them from the
top with a three-legged stool getting
ready to be the fourth
and then we have this entrepreneur
classes inside that university
so we're stepping on a lot of tolls with
free markets entrepreneurship
voluntary exchange and the same time
cleaning house over here
from an administrative level wow
jonathan warner says sir
when i was in training nearly a decade
ago you presented me and my brothers
with pizza
and a hell of a drag race with your
beautiful camaro you honored my brothers
that day and from the bottom of my heart
i thank you
appreciate you being out the races uh
the one thing i did love is
um running that z28 with uh
don schumacher uh lear pritchard
and um that whole team and um the one of
the things they did when i
when they asked me is they took my my
car away from me he wouldn't let me race
anymore so i missed those days at the
racetrack
with nhra that was fun to be with the
fans they're the greatest fans in the
world and i got to race that car and
then uh
to your point we got to give money away
um just about every other weekend for
the um
for some kind of charity sometimes
sometimes military yeah
all right this one is fantastic matter b
gaming says sell
ian is a pirate t-shirt for forty
dollars then give us the option to
download a copy for free
so we can see how much money is lost to
piracy love it
that's a good idea we've been we've been
arguing about whether pirate
downloading content uh that's being sold
and i i mentioned you guys beforehand
that if someone
idea for a future currency with our new
crypto thing would be if someone took my
digital art and sold it the crypto would
pay them
and me it would go to the creator's
wallet and then the
creator i could say like they get one
percent of the sale for selling my stuff
this is kind of off topic i'd rather
talk about pizza
all right a penny for your podcast says
papa john i got to know what's peyton
manning like in real life
peyton's funny he's cool what you see is
what you get
um he um we did a lot of commercials in
a short period of time
but got very close to he and
his wife ashley um had two um
two children twins um
marshall mosley um was friends with
archie and olivia
so i got pretty close to the family uh
eli
he just a class act uh another brother
cooper so
just a neat family good values and uh
great endorsement endorser of our
product
when this all went down he called me
said you know
what's up i go i had no idea what's
going on here
and i said you need to do one thing
peyton until i get to the bottom of what
they did you just need to stay clear of
me
and you know the phone kind of got quiet
i said you know i don't know how they
did this i don't know what they did
there's just no history of this
painting and i said but i just don't
want to tarnish your reputation
and i think he really appreciated that
and that was the last time we talked
wow i love that guy yeah wow wandering
mage says my father used to work for
papa john's a long time ago and he
always vouched for how well the pizza
was made
but we've noticed a drop in quality
recently can't have papa john's without
papa john i guess
stay strong papa john thank you god
bless i appreciate that and um
one thing um it's kind of like when you
get a little bit out of shape
you know you kind of like it's pain to
get back in shape
to make the pizza really well and run
the stores really really well
it's just hard it's every day and
they've gotten a little bit
out of shape and they know if i come
back in
first thing we're going to do is have to
clean our act up and i think that's a
little bit of uh
deterrent for the franchisees to want me
to come back
because we are going to if we if we do
get back if the if they crash the thing
which we've crashed it three times
before with bad product and bad service
and no measurements and no prints we've
done this before we've seen this movie
i've never seen it with kova and it's a
whole different environment
but the first thing you do is you have
to go back to the basics and the basic
is food quality and
great people and that's going to take a
lot of work it'll take
5 000 stores in the kind of shape it's
in it'll take a year and a half to get
them back in shape
did you ever experiment with drone
delivery service
no and i like it i like the drone i mean
i hope we can pull that off because
they're doing the cars now i think
domino's announced they got that car
that drives the pizza to your house
i like that concept because you can put
a central
kitchen in the middle of a city and not
have to build all these restaurants you
just build one giant kitchen and just
deliver the pizza with automatic
kitchens too yeah the pizza is all
automated the drone comes in through the
ceiling gets the pizza and then takes
off
i got a question like an amazon
warehouse it's it's there's a certain
amount of stores that are corporate and
certain amount of stores that are
franchise is that how it works
yeah when i left um approximately 5 000
stores 600
us corporate about 2 000 uh
international franchise and then about 2
400 uh north america franchisees
so yeah 600 corporate stores is what we
had when i left in
17. so are you allowed to open your own
franchise have your own
me now yeah i don't think they would go
for that we're not they're not very
happy with me right now and i'm not very
happy with them
i'd imagine if you did like people would
be like i'm gonna i'm going there
they would want to drive in and have
like the real papa john's
you know that's a distinct possibility
and i i don't have a non-compete
so i can go i can do whatever i want to
do and there's no power being amazing
the recipes don't have do they have
patents the recipes how does that work
i mean i know the recipe because about
recipes i mean i love others i have the
patent it's in my brain i don't know the
intellectual property rights are in my
brain i don't know if you can trademark
that you just use a little bit extra
sugar and then it like throws the entire
recipe off right changes everything
yeah but it's a little bit more
complicated than that in a good way
you can know the recipe but you still
don't walk the talk because to do the
recipe right costs more money
so the reason that they don't do the
original recipe to your call before last
is that they're trying to say
you know you've got big counters running
your business see they think they think
the consumer's stupid
they think well we'll cut this cut that
change that not measure it
you know make a less quality pizza but
you just heard it now we've had four
calls where people said the pizza's
slipping
that's right i remember in 95 the pizza
just was better i didn't know anything
about the ingredients i didn't even care
about health
when i was 14 but or 16 or whatever but
it was just better it was like four
bucks more
but better it would be like 12 bucks
instead of 10 or something but we were
so good that my entire family was just
that was the one when i when i saw
sucralose sucralose it's called in in
pizza huts dough
i'm i i set out i will never buy that
again no joke
i go to we we're driving we're going to
the skate park i go to a gas station i
see this drink in the thing and i'm like
oh that looks good
and it says like antioxidant fruit with
seltzer and i grab it
and then i buy it and then i crack it
open take a sip and i'm like whoa that's
really sweet and there it is boom
sucralose and i'm like garbage well
here's the deal the um
you know the fda comes in
from one of these food processors that
we talked about and says hey that
product
is inadequate and it's not upstanding
we're not going to pass it
that processor goes to their lobbyists
which are probably paying
a half million bucks a year that
lobbyist goes to that senator that
congressman says hey
you know the fda agencies jamming me up
here i need to get this product through
the center of whatever calls agencies
says hey if you don't pass the product
we're gonna we're gonna terminate you or
get rid of your agency so the agency
is at the beck and call of the lobbyist
i.e
you get all these chemicals and food our
food supply is poisonous
yeah potassium bromate particularly
scandal that's scandal it's terrible
d3fec wants me to in
inform and remind you john that the
phrase anti-racist means you support
racial discrimination against people
so uh anti-racism has become a specific
ideology that phrase is a proper noun
not just a general statement now so uh
i guess you'd say you opposed racism
your statement was meant to be in
opposition to racism
the the the author ibrahim kennedy was
his real name henry rodgers i guess yeah
yeah he's he's a prominent critical race
theorist or
at least a derivative of he writes he
has the book how to be an anti-racist
and he specifically tells people you
must discriminate on the basis of race
that's his ideology and i think it's
abhorrent but he's taken that phrase
anti-racism so that in these
circumstances when you
when a regular person says oh i i oppose
racism i'm anti-racist
they can that when that when people say
what's anti-racist they then show his
book which tells people to be racist
it's very confusing i know you know but
i guess the issue is
if you say you're anti-racist someone
will take that clip and then try and
spin it yeah i think i think at the end
of the day you you've got to look at
what's the intent
um i always look at where somebody's
hearts at if somebody
comes in and says you know by the way
tim
you look you look sharp today you know
or hey man i like
you know you're looking you know i mean
one's a compliment one
is you know put down but you said the
same right so it's always
i just look at the intent i look at the
heart you know
that's right but the media and the board
of directors and the universe they
certainly didn't
you give them the opportunity you know
but you know what to be honest i don't
think it mattered
um necessarily they would have found
something to twist if they were coming
after you they were coming after you
they were gonna
they were coming after me and it's it's
quite flattering
they couldn't have found enough other
stuff you know
to get rid of me so they had to
fabricate something there wasn't enough
meat on the bone to say we had a
violation of soybeans oxley or we have a
bad culture
or sales are bad or we're not making
enough money so what they do they go out
and fabricate
a false narrative with racism there's a
there's a less common saying
if somebody wants to steal your bike no
amount of bike locks will stop them
yeah you know uh so you know this is
something you that
hacker friends of mine have pointed out
and i think that's the comment among
many of my friends
if somebody if you want to get a
security system
it will stop the people who are passing
by who look in your window and your
door's locked and they'll keep walking
but if you are the target they're out to
get you they'll find a way so it sounds
like in your case they were just like
we'll take whatever we can get and we'll
make it the thing yeah
i i think i think i was a mark man yeah
crandall logan says john you need a
restaurant and please write this down
smithfield utah domino's just doesn't do
it at all
someone's got to open a franchise
smithfield utah papa john's i'm sure
you're listening to this get on the horn
get up get off your corporate heinen and
sell this as a franchise in smithfield
yeah how much you want to i i would i
think it's a very safe bet that
you know some pr firm working with papa
john's corporate is watching this show
oh they've got more shirts watching this
and quakers
we have like a ton of guys i'm like oh a
lot of viewers tonight i wonder if it's
all
pr when they actually have these board
meetings down in atlanta you know
because everybody talks i mean
they'll spend 20 30 percent of the board
meeting talking about my issues with me
i mean it's kind of funny did you own a
huge percentage of the company before
they fired you off the board i own the
um 30
of the company 31 to be exact
coop is saying that i'm incorrect it was
one million illegal crossings for the
month of june alone please stop saying
here
i thought it was the first six months
yeah i thought it was 180k in general
you want to google that just to be sure
i'm pretty sure it was 188 000 in just
this past month and it was a million for
the first
yeah six months we will get that fact
check we will see
let's see all right let's see
uh holly salcedo says papa john's was my
first job when i was a teen best
restaurant i've ever worked for
back in 2013. bless the papa rip joey
jordison
well thank you for that i appreciate
that that touches my heart i i
have heard a lot of people well i
shouldn't say a lot of people a couple
people
say that you know they worked for papa
john's and now we have this and they
said it was great it was the employees
were treated really well
we had scholarships for the employees
like i said we were the best place to
work in kentucky
it was it was magical it was really a
blessing from god to watch that thing
operate and
to give all these raises and all these
promotions i mean
just you know just watch the smile on
you know when people go home and
parents say you know i got a raise and
they tell their kids i mean
you know they get new cars they get new
homes i mean that's probably the most
gratifying thing of the whole
gig is when watch people get promotions
and get raises did your brother
oh did your brother stick with what was
the last thing you said my brother got
out in 2002
he clocked out for with like 40 million
oh awesome yeah
so he's the smart one in the family he
gets no publicity
no attention he's got homes in aspen
homes and you know
he's enjoying his life i'm up here on a
tuesday night doing a podcast with you
guys yeah so
we know he's got the brains of the
family you guys uh the papa john's
stores they teach the employees how to
make their pizza right right like
that ten point system you were telling
me about like the the people who make
the pizza know this
yes so we got the super chat from
randomonius
he says i haven't worked at pjp for
seven years now and even i can tell you
what is wrong with the pizza order
that's amazing yeah that's here when you
to really do a good job um you have to
have the pro
be proud of what you're doing and when
you're making good pizza and you know
it's good
you have an emotional attachment to your
job
so now all of a sudden we're and i've
heard this from franchisees they
the corporate really doesn't care what
we're serving just get it out the door
that lack of pride then that seeps down
the place is not clean
the service is not as good and you don't
take your job with the kind of
fondness or affection that you would if
you really made a good pizza so yeah
once you know how to make a good
papa john pizza it's with you for the
rest of your life would they use
bread machines to get the dough ready or
do they do it by hand
we never use machines they they're
putting dough machines in
um they it does save labor
um it does make that that uh position a
lot easier
i don't know enough about no machines to
say it's a lot better a lot worse i know
it's not better
but i can't really slam on dough
machines because i don't have a lot of
experience
but i can tell you that it's put in
there for cost savings
and usually when you save cost and it's
not 100 hand tossed then you're you're
probably sacrificing
quality the human heat seems like you
want to put your love and your spirit
into it i mean it's the heat your body
is like it seems like i mean i'm into
reich even have you seen the movie the
founder
yes they should make the founder too
papa john yeah
i'll let you produce it we'll do it
right here in your studio
but i agree with you and we just we just
need more love more love
yeah the interesting thing about the
movie the founder the reason i bring it
up
somewhat jokingly is that you had these
these two brothers who were very serious
about the quality of their food
and this guy comes in he's like nah fast
out the door powdered milkshakes
whatever by the land and it was very
corporate not quality you know and so
it's not the same story
but it's a similar story yeah we hear a
lot you're talking about
pasadena um san bernardino the
mcdonald brothers yeah they mac and bill
what was it but anyway
anyway um and uh croc came in
from illinois and uh he was selling
those multi-mixers
and they wanted 26 of them and they
bought 26 and he couldn't figure out why
they needed 26
mixtures until he went and visited and
he fell in love with mcdonald's
and he was croc was fanatical about what
he called qscnb
quality service cleanliness and value
and
at 500 stores mcdonald's actually lost
money
and they had a financial guy harry
stewborn they came up with the concept
let's buy the land and rent it to him at
10 percent of sales
wow so harry's two-born in the i think
late 60s early 70s actually came up with
a real estate play for mcdonald's
mcdonald's button built to like 1961 63.
remember white castle was 1921. crystal
was way back there burger chef was way i
mean
a lot of these concepts were 1940 1950
mcdonald's was late to the party i
didn't think behind burger chef and
burger king and yet
kroc pulled it off with a real estate
play that's how that worked yeah
diego williams says papa john best of
luck taking back what's yours my girl
and i love your philly pizza
also shout out for my girls art business
and make it her full-time go to
graylegart.com she does things by
commission
from animals to dnd characters and
fursonas
is that greylag art.com perhaps i
pronounce it looks like
all right let's see zip tie says the
beauty of being self-employed is that
you only work
half days and you get to choose but you
get to choose which 12 hours
howard taylor that's a good one yeah the
one thing
one problem i had when i was at papa
john's it seemed like every time i
stepped away
the thing kind of crashed and burned so
i was basically a prisoner of my own
creation
today rob lynch the ceo of papa john's
and the board of directors
they're basically prisoners of my
creation they're the ones that you know
i mean
i get dividends you know stocks at an
all-time high and i don't have to do
anything so
i like the fact that shaquille o'neal's
an employee you know we pay him to do
the ads
and we pay rob lynch as an employee and
he basically works for the shareholders
and
i like being an owner and letting them
be the employees and letting them be in
the prisoner of my creation so i don't
have to worry about it so
i do like the the half 12-hour days i
like that concept
yeah that's a good one all right bielit
says just became a member at tim cast
and bought 16 acres to homestead
and youtube channel called little tails
farm thanks for encouraging us to live
off grid
absolutely man i i've you know i lived
in cities for
my whole life we i lived briefly in uh
outside of miami
where i had some chickens and we had a
little bit of land but we didn't really
do much other than having some chickens
and then uh now we moved out here from i
was in new york
five years ago for a little while and
then we were in philly for a little bit
now we're out here now we got our own
chickens we got our own garden we're
growing our own vegetables
we got six six hens and a rooster the
rooster was an accident we didn't
realize we got a rooster
now we're not now they're up to lane
four eggs per day we got an incubator
and this is going to be real tough but
we've got a bunch of the eggs in the
incubator and it looks like there may be
like four or five
that are are growing and then we're
gonna have a bunch of baby chicks
and then we're gonna open up chicken
city and there's gonna be families and
there's
it's gonna be fantastic man so uh shout
out be lit good good good job
clef the misfit says i swear to god if
you don't make a vlog episode at papa
john's house making pizzas
and riding in the camaro then the whole
channel is pointless yes
yes requires travel but uh that's what
we that's why we have an airplane
yeah i i i gotta say i have to imagine
if you you personally made the pizza it
would be like the best pizza ever
we're gonna the plane holds 11. you you
get seven seats we'll send our pr folks
up here with you and you can come up to
pi
bring bring a couple cameras bring a
little audio
and uh come up to louisville we'll make
pizzas in the backyard drive the camaro
wow i'll show you i'll show you derby
city on papa style
how long does it take to fly from there
to here 50 minutes
50 minutes 50 50. 50 50.
so not even an hour no wow how's
the weekend weekend after next real i'm
serious
let me know i mean what do you think
about making sauces too complex
simplicity of ingredients if you go back
to pluto
i think you know bc um
he has a saying what was great
architecture what was great engineering
what was great poetry
uh simplicity and if you really watch
somebody that's really gifted
take tim and watch what he does he makes
it look you know or you take a sculpture
you take watch tiger woods hit a golf
ball
they make it look so easy and common and
what we have found that the key to
complexity
you know the universal complexities
actually are achieved through
the porthole of simplicity so i like
anything that's simple
simple works real good and the ultimate
sophistication for anybody is to be able
to take something really really complex
and make it simple people the corporate
folks especially if you get technology
people
they take things that are real simple
and they get complicated
and then you're lost you're confused so
that's that that's the opposite of what
pluto would do or what i would recommend
so
uh sauce less is better less yeah yeah
all right so we're going to do a couple
more couple more super chats
yeah uh and then the last question we
have for you is one of the most
important questions
that that you could ever possibly answer
but first alex
maggiore says quality has gone down the
toilet in the last two years
it was my family's favorite and now we
don't go there anymore i hope you can
save the name from columbus ohio
i'm sure it kind of sucks to hear a lot
of people saying you know things like
this but
you know a lot of people have that have
those comments
but now for the most important uh super
chat the most important question
so that you can settle the age-old
debate
fantasy says tim can you please ask the
papa if pineapple belongs on pizza
hawaiian pizza's ham and pineapple
i've never been a fan you know it's not
one of our big sellers but people do eat
pineapple on pizza i i
whether you agree or disagree now hawaii
they love pineapple ham pizzas that's
why they call we i think we call it
hawaiian but no
um it's uh pineapples um it's it's more
than anchovies
you know i like anchovies yeah
i don't even like putting them on the
pizza oh wow i like anchovies it
saltifies the cheese yeah it's very
salty
but the pineapple thing's always been
weird to me it's like why not kiwi it's
like why not
cherry why not let's go let's let's
let's make it happen
if you got to treat it right because if
it's too tart it's gonna
it's gonna impact the acidity of the
cheese
you know so you wanna you wanna like
mute the tartness of the fruit that's
why pineapples bake
pretty well all right ladies and
gentlemen this has been a blast uh
so thank you all so much for hanging out
watching smash that like button go to
timcast.com become a member we'll have a
bonus segment coming up
usually goes up around 11 or so pm you
can follow the show at tim cast irl you
can follow me personally at
timcast is there anything you want to
mention before we before we go well just
thank you for having me and tim that was
delightful thanks pleasure
lindy appreciate you and i just have one
request when when i die
just make sure i don't vote democrat
oh geez follow me and cross on this
fantastic thanks man this is great
love it yeah i really enjoyed this
conversation tonight i was just enjoying
listening and i didn't want to say i did
get that fact check for that person who
was saying that a million people came in
in june this is not correct according to
the texas tribune
up to june it has been 1 million people
180 000 people in the month of june you
guys are more than welcome to follow me
at sour patch
it's on twitter as i attempt to gain
more followers and sour patch kids
thank you all so much for hanging out
we'll see you over at timcast.com bye
guys
you